and we are live ready for this i'm not a
gm speed chess championship match
between gotham chess levy rosman
and i am rosen eric rosen i'm on it's
gonna be a heavyweight battle two of the
most popular streamers
on the web who's gonna take this one
that's a great question robert and when
we're all looking for the answer for i
saw the
chat poll right before you and i went
live here and it was
neck and neck i think 45 to 43
with the remaining going there cat jam
or some guy i've never heard of but
it is going to be a super close one and
i love that we're uh
got this prime time slot robert really
feels you mentioned heavyweight matchup
i think that uh you know this is going
to be one of the most exciting matches
in the entire competition
it certainly will be and the everyone in
the audience is familiar with the
players let's remind them of the format
so to get used to what we'll see as the
night goes on
it is a single elimination knockout
brackets the loser of this match
well you're not continuing in this
tournament it is 75 minutes
of five minute plus one second increment
blitz followed by 45 minutes of the
three plus one and finally we get to 25
minutes of bullet
and the winner moves on and of course we
have the prize fund
it is 300 and more importantly advancing
the semifinals
and then the rest 300 is split by win
percentage and i'm on as we take a look
at the bracket how we got here where
we're going it is the bottom left-hand
side of the bracket we have levy rosman
as the four seed
eric rosen as the five seed and this is
just the matchup everyone's been waiting
for
yeah this is uh as you can see from the
bracket there this is basically the
final
spot that we have to fill um in the the
semi-finals leading into the finals so
this is going to determine everything
that you know the winner is going to
move on
to play against greg shahade which is
he's the number one seed in the whole
thing so
right after this match no matter who
wins you're guaranteed another
big matchup as the winner is going to
take on craig
that's for sure the case and it's almost
nine on the east coast
everyone here in the audience is feeling
fine i see the chat going crazy
because they're excited about gotham
chess versus i am rosen
and well we can see the players right
now we can bring them on screen for you
they've got their hoodies on they're
you know they're ready for this match
and i wonder if they're nervous
to you know settle score here and
determine
which of these two is going through to
the semi-finals
yeah it's it's really really tough to
call um
this matchup i think on paper the
players are so
similarly rated and if i had to pick
someone who
uh i guess maybe would be more nervous i
feel like i might say
levy and that's just based on his
post-game interview that he gave in the
last match where he was like
you know listen i have to admit i was a
little nervous and uh rosen always seems
so cool
and and so calm but who knows you know
what's hiding behind the facade
that does appear to be the case most of
the time and we know what it's like
commentating the pressures off
we want to bring entertainment and
education to
the masses but you don't feel that same
pressure like when you are playing
and for levy who during the day has been
covering the champions chess tour
and of course providing excellent
content going up on youtube daily
now he has to pick up the pieces himself
and take on a very strong opponent eric
rosen
yeah and you've uh talked to so many
different players over the course of
this i'm not a gm competition
so many other content creators are
actually commentators themselves so
you know with all work that levy's been
doing commentating
you make a good point you know kenny
transitioned back to a
very very uh intense matchup that
he's gonna have to deal with uh eric
rosen i mean they're so evenly matched
in blitz
and bullet um i i think that uh on paper
this
might be the closest matchup rating wise
yeah it is very close probably about 50
points separate them but it's at the
different time controls because there is
that one second increment
you can't flag your opponents as easily
and let's say you're used to playing
hyper bullet rather than
one minute bullet it just affects the
same rating but it's a different game so
it's going to be an interesting battle
and we're just a minute away now the
chat is
really stoked and they're picking their
sides that's clear
yes they are i saw a gifted sub bomb
from chesapeake in the chat there to
energize the people and maybe give them
a few extra emails to spam
and i mean the the chat right now is
energized robert as i mentioned i'm just
hyped for this prime time slot
we don't get to commentate too many of
these matches in the evening and it just
it just always makes things feel more
prime time
it for sure does and the players they're
stretching they're getting
yeah their bodies ready to sit in these
chairs and compete in intense
blitz chests for the next few hours and
you know eric
i feel like it's hard to tell if he's
winning or losing just by body language
because he has that same mannerisms
regardless and
for levy i think it's important him to
start on a good note because against
canty it didn't feel like he found his
footing
until the latter part of the
three-minute portion canty was
really keeping with him game by game
there
and then finally lead was able to break
free and you could sense that confidence
and levy's been working really hard i
saw he played alexander castaneuk that's
chess queen
in a match so he's taking this seriously
he's getting his practice reps in
and eric rosen also taken seriously he
said hey when i'm
playing these events i take a bit of a
break from streaming to focus on my
studying
and i love that i think that's how the
players should treat these events um
i think what i've noticed from this
edition of the i am not a gm tournament
is that most players
have uh said that that is the case you
know they have taken time off from what
they're usually doing
and put a lot of effort into their
matches you know some people even said
well you know i'm preparing for these
matches more than my
you know my own uh commentary or my own
over the board games whatever it is
so i i just like to see that from the
players they are fully committed to
these matches
and um i think that levy is now in a
position where he knows that eric rosen
is you know
a very tough even match for him and uh
you know what they say you often play up
to the standards of your opponent so
maybe he felt as the favorite in the
last match that
you know he he wasn't supposed to play
maybe his best chess and he might win
anyway well now he's gonna have to play
his best chess and we do have liftoff we
see that
levy's going for this g3 he's going to
fee and kettle the bishop take the long
diagonal this has the
feel of a catalan the difference being
that white hasn't committed this pawn to
d4 yet
and i generally like this position
stylistically for white you get a
bit of a plus just with your piece
quality
but the problem can be if you don't
recapture that c4 pawn
that can be a problem especially in a
blitz game yeah and there's a lot of uh
you know theory and preparation that
goes into some variations where you try
to keep this pawn
you know with the b5 and a6 or rook b8
um
you know and for white often you might
see a queen a4 move early on just to
make sure that you get this pawn back
and you don't have to deal with
positions where uh you're sort of
getting concerned well hang on
am i getting that pawn back at all and
look at this queen a4 knight d7
breaking the pin on the knight and c6
and after queen takes over knight b6
hitting the queen
bringing both knights over to the queen
side and then finally black can finish
development but
let me ask you what if you play move
okay you want queen c2 i was thinking of
queen c3 how do you get that dark squish
square bishop out but instead the queen
drops to c2 which is its natural habitat
yeah i was um even yeah okay so i was
wondering about the move e5 and the
reason being that if black is gonna you
know take the time to cycle his knight
away from
what most of us would consider a very
natural square f6
there has to be something that he's
planning if he's just going bishop e7
and castling i'm wondering why you put
the knight there and
it looks like with the move e5 bishop e7
uh we're almost transposing
back to you know a different line of
theory where um in the english black
plays d5
and captures and then puts the knight on
b6 so i don't know what the
move count is here robert but maybe
we're back in some sort of theory in
english
yeah and it's a reverse sicilian right
where white is missing the c
pawn and this would be black and
sicilian and then you see the position
arise like this and eric plays a5 he's
taking up space in the queen side he's
stopping b4
and levy plays the thematic bishop e3
that may look weird to some putting your
bishop in front of the pawn
but it's attacking the knight on b6
excuse me and also the bishop can plant
himself on c5 if you want to start
taking over
squares on the c file yeah that's a
great point and if people are wondering
you've already mentioned that as sort of
a reverse sicilian
just think about the dragon setup and
it's actually really common for black to
play bishop e6 in that setup it's the
exact same thing here
so in some cases this bishop can even be
taken and white would say you know f
takes e3 sure i get
the open file and i control the d4
square probably what eric's going to be
looking to do
at some point you know rookie 8 and
knight d4
there's going to be a moment where
there's a choice from uh
um eric rosen here do i play knight d4
uh and he's gotta time that correctly
that's right h4 plane and f6 the
immediate response
and f6 kind of says to h4 well you're
not getting that g5 square for your
piece
now my knight on c6 is free to move
because e5 is well defended and i would
consider
a4 especially after rook d1 give me that
b3 square if i get my bishop to b3
i skewer your queen and then your rook
so now that the rook is on d1 i'm even
more tempted to play that move
yeah a4 is uh really natural in these
positions anyway it looks like after a4
bishop takes b6 you can even throw in
that bishop d3 move
intermezzo to make sure that you don't
drop the a4 upon that's right because
that would be a big pawn to drop just
push it there and then lose it
but that intermezzo could play into
black's hands although there are
positions where you can just sacrifice
an exchange
and claim that you get a bishop and a
pawn for your troubles or knight and
upon in this case
and that might be worth it for the rook
yeah and it looks like d4
is the consideration here so roseanne i
mean if not a4
which maybe tactically deals with d4 i
was going to say
he needs some solution here because
after playing the move f6
d4 for white is usually the central
break that causes some problems and
knight ends up on d4
all of a sudden it's hitting the bishop
on e6 the knight on c6 the bishop on g2
opens up on that long diagonal and the
rook on d1 opens up against the queen
and we're seeing a major drawback of the
pawn being on h4 rather than on h2
because
in the sicilian if you think about from
the perspective of a sicilian for the
black pieces you could sometimes allow
this knight to capture the bishop on e3
but levy was kind of forced to react
because allowing that capture now would
leave the g3 pawn vulnerable
so that's why he took first but now
black played e4 the knight
moves away and then f5 and that pawn on
e4 is such a thorn
in the bishop on g2 side yeah completely
agree this is what you don't want
usually
as white so i'm getting the feeling that
this is uh trending in a good direction
for rosen
after knight d2 f5 as you mentioned and
again if that pawn was on h2 you might
consider something like f3 to break the
position down but
that pawn up to h4 is looking like a
move that levy's gonna want back
and look at that eric just pre-moves f5
and you're right that
that pawn would love to go back to h2
you feel safer for your king
now their idea is to sacrifice on h4 and
push your pawn to f4 you have to keep an
eye on that
it looks very dangerous already for levy
and he doesn't have a concrete plan
that's the issue when you get into a
position with that bishop on d5
it really stops all of white's play
white would actually love to throw that
d4 pawn off the board and give me the
open file give me space for my pieces
but that bishop 1d5 blockades the whole
center yeah and bishop f6
just watching that e5 uh square where
the knight might want to jump in
i think if levy can get maybe bishop f4
and e3
in with rook ac1 you know that's sort of
the long-term setup he might want to go
for
controlling the e5 square and uh you
know his his rooks are certainly much
better placed
than than eric's rooks at the moment
that's true and i might be probably like
to here and play a4 just say hey
please go 95 you know move that knight
because i want to get my bishop to b3
and eric plays queen eight this makes
sense the pawn's on h4 it's
you can go for a king side attack with
queen h5 or something like that or
just put your queen on a square like e
e6 or f7
and go for bishop to p3 if that knight
ever moves out the way
you can get that skewer at long last
yeah queen e6 queen f7 i like e6 because
f7 feels like it's going to be hit at
some point with a knight like 95 so
queen e6 looks like a great square for
that a4 we've mentioned a few times
definitely a big consideration and levy
is i'm pretty sure looking at the move
95 it was
probably playable in that last position
um knight e5 but
you know eric doesn't have to take that
that's right and here queen e6 you can
still try for 95 but now i'm going to
take it because i have my bishop
and my queen protecting that e5 square i
will win a pawn and my bishop 155 can be
protected by the pawn coming to c6 so
bishop f4 played
and all right i just see the eval bar
drop which means knight takes d4
followed by c5 is probably just a
knockout
yep yep that looks uh that looks strong
there however
it's something that you would think
twice about you know in a game because
it looks like there might be some maybe
rook moves to consider
some rook takes d5 rook takes e4 there's
just a few extra things to calculate but
if you look at the clock i think eric
does have the time to maybe notice that
i see now why levy played the move queen
c3
he wanted that setup that i've been
talking about so much bishop f4 and e3
but eric has to strike right now
otherwise he's going to achieve that
and he does go rook f7 so knight takes
d4 it's hard to play that because
it looks like there are some variations
where white gets a bunch of pieces for
that queen
and it's not so clear to figure out
who's on top so he goes rook f7
now that knight can come to e3 and
that's what levy does bishop b3 no
longer the same threat there could be
some d5
ideas and all complications in that
position
and aristotle think again before playing
bishop to b3 it might be a good move but
d5
is what would make me nervous about it
absolutely no i
usually you do not want that bishop to
leave and then d5 and look at all the
pieces it's like taking on e6 takes on
f7 with check every piece in eric's
position
is sort of on the wrong square for that
d5 push and he plays it so
if d5 you know what's funny he can just
go bishop back and take on d5
i was thinking oh do i take the queen
and then you take my queen on e6
but he can just take the pawn right back
on d5 and then say hey your queen's
still under attack
yeah now it's your turn again yeah it's
uh it's easy to overlook that kind of
stuff so eric
props him for playing bishop to b3 but
also levy has worked his way and
created some threats because even if you
don't have d5 right now
you can line that up in the near future
absolutely i mean
rook d2 is definitely playable knight c2
um knight c2 looks playable as well
you're gonna get some e3 and one thing
to be careful of is this light squared
bishop as soon as it comes alive in the
position
be careful like bishop f1 to c4 in the
future or bishop h3 targeting f5
that's right and a4 was a very important
move speaking of light square bishops
that bishop on b3 was hanging if the
queen got distracted so knight takes f5
was a distraction tactic to win the
bishop on b3 for that knight but that's
why a4 is so strong it cements that
bishop in place
also you could think about playing
knight a5 at some point or even rook a5
depending on the situation
if you want to use that square for one
of your pieces yeah rook a5
is a fun move to play but you always got
to make sure that that knight is not
leaving the c6 square
uh as the queen is hitting the a5 square
wait knight f1 uh-oh
amman levy had 3.3 seconds left
he has been using all of his time the
clock management has not been a strong
suit
of his even in the past match so he
needs to speed up and this position is
way too complicated to have three
seconds in
yeah i mean all eric has to do is
basically bring rooks to the d file i
would guess like rook d7 rook d8
uh to be honest the way that he was not
playing quickly
made me not maybe think like wait this
guy can't have one second what's going
on here rook c8
roxy it wins the rook on c1 is
unprotected and you have to give your
queen
that looks like after queen d7 you just
say i have a queen for a rook in one
pawn that should be enough
and levy has 1.8 seconds left bishop h3
though is a move you can count on next
almost you know pre-movable um taking
that f5 pawn
i think yeah he's ready for that
really nice move and now you can just
take on f5 and the bishop e6 maybe is
sufficient but rook c7 comes it's a
little bit tricky
so eric does need to be careful he
should use some of his time here
and absolutely what is the best way to
go because rook c7 then bishop takes f5
it starts looking a bit problematic for
black so maybe even consider knight
takes d6 you are going to lose your
knight
but you will lose it you know after
bishop f5 queen f5 rook takes d6 you
have this bishop on b3 so queen and
bishop versus two rooks
i think he's can like yeah i think he's
maybe going to play this he decides to
take rook c7 it's gonna happen
um and then just queen d8 yeah that's
com
um but maybe he would try d7 there rook
takes b7
again it should be winning i think at
this point knight takes d6 is fairly
reasonable you already mentioned it just
lose the knight
your king's not getting mated and that
bishop and queen should do damage on the
light squares around the king
and one of the big things is that pawn
were on h2 the white king would feel
safer
but at some point the move like e3 for
black will make the white king very
vulnerable
mm-hmm yep and this this is gonna be too
much here there's no more pin you don't
even lose the knight
and knight e5 will be game over yeah
into those light squares they go and now
there's queen e6 queen h3 with mate
and many checkmates here and went on
time
wow i have to say uh robert until you
pointed it out i got
lulled into the the same false sense of
security that
uh levy maybe got himself into where
what
where did that time go we he's got to be
playing way faster there's no way that
the you can just have your time expiring
right in the middle of the well the
middle game that was surprising and levy
has struggled with this
in his match against james kent he said
it afterwards he's like i was just
moving too slowly
and you cannot afford to have three
seconds left at that point of the game
when it's so complicated
what is this knight a3 knight c2 against
the exchange cairo like is
is that typical i always felt you
supposed to get your bishop out to f4
which is why
uh levy put his queen on c7 before eric
could do that but what's the knight
doing on c2 exactly
well it's an interesting movie when you
start with knight a3 uh first of all you
threaten knight b5 and most players are
going to play a6 out of instinct
if you don't play a6 usually knight b5
the queen moves and then knight e2
and you're threatening bishop f4 so it's
kind of annoying it makes you waste a
move with a6
and then it on c2 after move like e5 is
very well positioned to take over the d4
square
that's right you're over protecting that
square and that's what you want to do
when your opponent has an isolated queen
pawn an iqp
like the one on d5 you want to blockade
with a knight to d4 often and then
you make sure it can't move then you
start putting pressure on it and try to
win it so right now
you don't need to put the knight in d4
that pawn of course cannot move safely
so i would consider just castling maybe
developing my dark square bishop to f4
and g5
and okay it goes to f4 this looks like a
promising star at least from my
perspective but that's a stylistic
choice
and levy's going for activity whereas
eric is the better pawn structure
yeah and uh it's not like one side's
better than the other it's that constant
struggle in chess whenever there's an
imbalance both sides are trying to prove
that they have the better side of it so
that isolated queen pond
always affords the side with the
isolated pawn a little bit more piece
activity control of the center
we see this e4 and c4 squares both where
those knights can jump in
and you know he flipped the board eric
rosen on the other hand you can target
that pawn it's going to need defense
constant defense but levy and that great
d4 square that's what you're supposed to
do occupy and control the square in
front
of the isolated pawn and look at levi
getting active queen to b6
eyeing that b2 pawn you don't really
want to give that pun up but there could
be a possibility you trap the queen if
it takes you that's always a dangerous
poison pawn to take so right now eric
trying to figure out do i need to
play rook to b1 that would be the safe
move and if eric were just trying to
play
speedy chess that's the move you play
instantly okay i'm just defending it but
he could have castled i think
because that queen would have been in no
man's land on b2
yeah it's it was definitely maybe
possible especially with black's king
still in the middle but
you know what it's the type of position
where you better be safe than sorry so
rook b1 covering the b2 pawn
castling's always available and uh you
know white might want to get something
like
just h3 in castling and then finally
occupy that d4 square with one of his
knights
and the knight on c2 is really powerful
actually because bishop g4
would be a nice move but then you can
play knight e3 and you're attacking the
bishop on g4 and if the bishop moves to
h5 the f5 square that knight can jump
right in there
and cause some problem for black so i'm
suddenly appreciating this knight a3 to
c2 maneuver and look at that
h5 trying to go h4 and go after this
bishop and maybe play h3
and pry open the light squares it's an
interesting move because i feel like h3
for white is so
natural i was going to play it anyway
when i see h5 i don't want to play h4
because of the g4 square so maybe just
h3 and if h4
either bishop back to f4 or bishop to h2
and um
not seeing any issue with that and eric
plays
knight to d4 and if black was h4 you
cannot play bishop f4 this is a common
tactic
there are pieces staring each other
those bishops through the 95
and once that knight takes the bishop on
d3 with check the bishop on f4 would be
hanging for free that tactic doesn't
work right now
because the bishops defend so h4 the
required move is bishop takes e5 which i
think eric is okay doing
because of this isolated pawn and the
blockade and then he can safely castle
his king
yeah safely castles king if queen e2
pinning the bishop after that black
could actually castle in that position
um because there's rookie eight so it's
actually a funny position because romu
14 robert
neither king is castled black's king
could technically still castle queenside
don't expect it but uh for eric rosen i
mean we're expecting short castle
sometime in the near future
and counts and queen said there is a
common idea in these types of positions
but it's dangerous right because without
the c pawn your king feels a little less
safe
though you are the one with all your
pieces over there like the bishops on d7
and d6 your knight on e5
it feels like maybe you can get away
with it but it does have
quite a bit of risk of course yeah and
this bishop i mean
on g3 can drop back to f2 where it's
going to put pressure on the queen on b6
but
uh levy's got no issue playing queen c7
in the near future and because
eric rosen has played f3 uh that h2 pawn
with so you know bishop on d6 queen on
c7
is a something that's really hard to
defend you play h3
all of a sudden look at those dark
squares around the king yeah that's not
a movie you really want to see
and right now eric thinking so he is
down on the clock levy
handling clock much better at this point
he has nearly three minutes the position
remains complicated so you will need to
use that time
as the game goes forward and right now
eric's struggling to figure out do i
castle maybe i can make move like bishop
f5 that way i don't have to give up the
bishop pair maybe i'll trade the light
square bishops
get the f5 square for the knight and he
says okay 905 right away
forget about the bishop trade don't
really like this move
uh to be honest because uh i'm a little
concerned about the fact that the queen
on b6
uh prevents white from castling and the
rook on b1 means we know that queen side
castling is not happening so
i'm concerned about even just mass
trades let's say everything trades
e3 f5 g3 in black just castle safely
like
i'm concerned about some positions where
uh rosen
might not be able to to get his king
there as quickly as he wants
yeah it seems like a bad combination of
moves that you play f3 and then go
knight f5
as you're saying the king can't castle
the dark scores of vulnerable a timely
bishop f2
could help you out and right now levy's
just trying to figure out what my
partner g7 is under attack the bishop on
d6 is under attack
which pieces do i want to capture do you
want to take on d3 first before i take
on f5
should i take on f5 immediately and you
know do i just castle king's side that's
one of the big questions here and i
think he will take on
f5 because g7 is hanging and
it looks like it then what's the follow
up though did you just castle king side
because
that pawn h5 is starting to bother me
yeah the other option was uh actually
taking on g3
and i like the potential idea of keeping
the bishop on d7 so if white ever gets
castled or there's always these ideas
like bishop d5
that's true and he decides to just
castle
but now viking castle right bishop takes
d6 queen takes e6 and then
quickly castle king's side before the
queen can get back in the diagonal
and what about rook e8 check after
bishop d6
i'll probably call bishop e5 and just
say hey i can hoard my pieces i'm gonna
up
one here so i will just bring the bishop
right back although that would be two
rooks for a queen
possibly yeah in some of these scenarios
and that's a lot to take in
that's an interesting imbalance uh i
think that it's probably playable for
both sides uh
you know the the evaluation is very
close to you know dead center here
because i think what maybe this is
slightly better for white generally you
prefer the rooks but
i think with the queen and the knight
that the knight is crucial
uh the fact there's a knight on the
board and that f3 has been played
uh i think i think this is playable for
both sides that's true and
the reason why i would prefer the white
side is that d5 pawn is isolated but
then i would prefer the black side
because of all these weak dark squares
and the queen
can just be such a nuisance and g6 look
at that move included
and if you play queen f4 there was
knight d7
and that point was that the pawn
couldn't then defend the bishops the
queen g5 is very precise
and if knight d7 now you just play f4
and protect that bishop with a pawn
so there is some danger that if levy
does not take on e5 and give up the tour
for the queen
that he may not get his piece back at
least not on even material turns
yeah and i think we're i think we have
to see brooke takes e5 here
for those wondering about the queen for
two ropes that robert and i keep
referencing
it's going to happen after rook takes e5
queen takes c5 rook e8 the other rook
from the corner
and then the queen will be pinned to the
king so the best course of action looks
to be to simply give it up on e8
followed by bringing in knight to d4 and
then white will be able to castle
but it'll be uh pawns even and just
queen for two rooks so very classic
chess and balance i'm on
the time is not even levy's under 30
seconds and
if you are going to give up your rooks
for the queen you can't do it when you
have 29 seconds it just
won't be good and now that bishop is
protected that bishop is protected on e5
and what is black's move here maybe h4
to distract the queen
because f6 is met with queen takes g6
check so he does throw an h4 that's a
good move
and after queen f4 now i guess you have
f6
as a way to win that piece back but it's
not like black's king is so thrilled
about pushing these pawns up
well remember white can go queen you
know to f4 or
f6 like queen d4 something like that and
after rookie five just move the king
right it's not the end of the world
and i question whether you know black is
happier uh or white is happier with the
pawns on f6 g6
h4 as you mentioned like that that could
simply just backfire
uh in levees facing with 20 seconds left
these are weaknesses you can't take back
no they're not queen before played and
these end games will be
pleasant for white against that isolated
pawn he takes an e5 a check king f2 i
think is better
he plays that and queen b5 this to hit
the e2 square
i'm not going to allow you to check me
there same with queen e6 rook hd1
and thankfully that knight on c2 is
there that's been a hero piece when all
said done because it protects the e1
square so
the rooks can keep on going use that
square forever
yeah and i was just going to say i
really like the idea of getting h3
in it looks like you know kind of
whatever does not a big deal but
the knight is going to eventually come
to g5 and you want to loosen up that
king side position
with h3 so the f3 square is weaker white
on the other hand wants to probably get
some sort of queen d2 knight d4
in right and what's left is move in
eight seconds you gotta move
like it moves like knight g5 is tempting
but you calculate f4 fork in the rook
and knight so then you convince yourself
out of it
and now i'd play rook b to d1 remember
that knight on c2 protects the rook on
e1
and my immediate threats go rook takes
e5 and queen takes d5 winning that pawn
that problem pawn that's been there for
a while so rook beatty one threatens
just to win material
yeah it's it's weird rook b to d1 it's
easy to be deterred by rook e2 check
because you certainly don't want to take
that uh and mate yourself in two moves
there is king f1 available and he
decides to take which is
not a decision i would take because look
at the f-file now suddenly knight g5
queen f6 rook f8 everything seems to be
coordinating and queen five is a great
way to start
that's a great move hitting the knight
c2 the knight can't really move because
the rook is hanging behind it if you
play rook c1 in comes rook f8 knight g5
and look erika stevens yeah how did that
happen
oh my goodness wow the knight g5 rook i
faded e4 there's so many good moves here
where's knight g5
no knight f6 is too passive and rookie
one played with 2.9 94 check winning
material so it looks like levy's getting
this there's a queen d5 check
and he's trying to win some pawns back
for the material but levy blocks the
queen f7 this looks like
it is levy's game but you got to move
you might lose on time
queen f5 is a great move knight e3 oh
the nerves the nerves yeah we'll see who
has the better nerves here because
that's
one pawn taking the f3 pawn could be
loose later and neither king is safe oh
but if you trade queens that's got to be
a loss
yeah the problem is queen d2 is such a
strong threat um
and this is still going to require a
conversion here
you know as levy's guardian at f3 pawn
but
finally he brings his king and i think
that's the way to go yeah and rook at
four now hits the knight hits both pawns
on g4 and
on b4 and yeah this is
too many pawns for black and the rook is
too strong yeah just watch out for that
awful fork but rook g2 taking on h2 is
going to seal the deal
and a2 would hang next so he moves the
pawn but that h-bone is about to queen
so you have to
okay h2 and there's a promotion yeah
and this will be it by the way the time
is uh not enough here
and somebody who doesn't resign very
frequently is eric rosen he plays the
games out he gets
these tricky stalemates and things like
that but of course levy converts that
one nice
game there it was really topsy-turvy at
points but levy
he composed himself despite the
horrendous time trouble
and he strikes and gets on the
scoreboard and something to remember
about this match
is uh there's two sides to every coin
robert there's of course uh levy is
putting himself in crazy crazy time
trouble but
if there's someone who can get himself
out of this crazy crazy time trouble
it's also levy so
you live by this or die by the sword
it's kind of part of his style it's just
he plays a bit slower because
he's so confident in his bullet chest
that when you're playing these five
minute games he's like oh okay i got 30
seconds
like he plays 30 seconds chess you know
what he's not gonna
feel like 30 seconds is him being low on
time it's only when he's under five
seconds that he really realizes
and eric could have had a similar
problem with he had so much extra time
and then he burned it all and suddenly
he was the one who was down on the clock
under five seconds so
that was a really nerve-wracking game
and credit to levy for putting all the
piece in the e-file creating some
threats
and if i'm being honest that rookie two
check i didn't even see
it i should have seen it that the rook
had stopped there but after king f1 as
you showed in that previous game
that white was still doing well but
that's why eric took on e5
and levy turned those tables real quick
and was able to launch an attack
yeah and we're already into this next
game the moves are flying
uh we have an interesting opening here
where there's a major imbalance
basically black has this b4 square
uh has the b file for himself white is
putting pressure on the c file and
definitely has a
a slight lead in development here ideas
like knight e5
and knight b5 come to mind maybe bishop
f4 targeting the c7 pawn so hey
what about the move c5 uh looking to
trade the c pawn for the center pawn
and all things considered structurally i
think black is doing well
black has a really nice looking position
and one important thing is the pawn's an
a7
because if one of the white pieces wants
to go the b5 square you can play a6 like
if the knight gets in there to kick it
out whereas that b4 square
that's an outpost white does not have a
pawn that can kick any of black's pieces
out and so rook coming to b8 soon
it looks like it can be very promising
for eric and he is
a bit ahead on the clock we're gonna say
this often it feels like in the match
but he already has a lead of
almost 30 seconds and if he can maintain
that
with the strong central pawn structure
he has that pawn on d5 really good
one then he should have the upper hand
as this game continues
yeah and uh takes on c5 here and the
reason
that you know uh the evaluation maybe is
hovering a little bit closer to the
middle
uh there 0.00 is probably because that
bishop's not quite developed yet for
mr rosen so there's you know knight d4
ideas knight b5 ideas
and sometimes there's even and i was
about to say it the move e4
and you do this because that bishop is
not quite developed yet and you you
burst the center wide open and who's
going to benefit uh when the center
opens up robert it's going to be the guy
who's the lead in development
although one way to kind of counter that
development bishop a6 right now because
you played e4
my bishop can develop and attack your
rook on f1
and if you have to move your rook to e1
then i get a turn maybe queen b6 hitting
the f2 pawn
it could be some danger there and eric
does play bishop a6 and i'm
expecting levy to e takes d5 sacrifice
in exchange rip open the position
and let the bishops fly free but that's
a risky move
when you have to give up material yeah
it's a uh
it's something to consider because the
other option rookie one he's probably
looking at the move queen b6 and saying
wait a minute how do i
you know defend f2 because after queen
b6 let's not forget
that e pawn is going to be hanging the
bishop pinning the knight on f6 to the
queen after queen b6 remember that pin
is not there anymore
that's right and knight g4 moves happen
fast before you know it
f2 falls so that could be very dangerous
and levy trying to figure this out he
can go knight b5 as well
to block that bishop's attack of the
rook but then the e4 pawn is really
without defenders so that looks
pretty risky so i don't know like the
way he's thinking
it makes it hard for me to you know tie
together
thinking and giving up the material so
he does play knight to b5
which gives up the pawn with d takes e4
but there are going to be tactics with
the knight pinned on f6 the bishop one
c5 a bit loose
the knight on d7 doing kind of the
hero's work right now covering
everything
yeah absolutely knight b5 i think was
probably a decent decision
because i did not like the look of
rookie one queen b6 and
uh you know going into that position he
would have to expect
to give up the exchange if you're not
prepared to do that it's not a decision
you can make
just you know on the fly yeah so
we see that d64 is happening now the
knight can move to d2 but even
e3 is a possibility for black like when
you win a pawn sometimes you just push
it and
try to create a worse pawn structure for
your opponent that's a great point and
the other thing that
is involved with that e3 idea is that
black does not care
about bishop takes a8 you know in a lot
of positions that that bishop on g2
is probably levi's best piece and you
give that up
look how weak the white king is going to
be so e3 definitely a consideration here
you know queen b6 can can happen all the
same but e3 looks like the
kind of fun testing move right i like e3
it just
hurts your opponent's pawn structure and
that's all i'm looking for and if that
bishop were to leave g5 that bishop and
c5 can take on e3 with check in some
lines so there's a lot to calculate
especially with that rook and
hanging but i'm kind of willing to
sacrifice that rook
everything opens up i haven't calculated
fully but i feel like black should not
be unhappy about that kind of transition
yep um he's thinking a lot here so rosen
is investing
his time back into the position knight
d2 played i wonder what else he could be
thinking of because queen
maybe b6 is the only thing but knight
takes e4
just it looks like a move you don't want
to allow it hits the bishop on c5 and if
you play knight takes e4 there's bishop
takes e4
hitting the rook in the corner the queen
will then be hitting the knight on d7
so that's all stuff for rosen to
consider yeah that
opening of the position favors a bishop
on the longest diagonal the bishop one
g2
you're pointing out the bishop on c8
wasn't doing much the bishop on a6
perhaps not doing as much either except
for being captured knight and e3
was played here so that hits the knight
on d2 he immediately takes back
and i think i would consid i would
really consider taking that knight on b5
because
it's just bothering me and then putting
my rook on b8 but then that c6 square
we've seen this happen
in previous matches where there's a pawn
on b5 a bishop getting into c6 and that
could
be really annoying rook c8 is a nice
move that deals with a lot of things at
once
it deals with obviously the rook being
hit in the corner and it adds some
support to the bishop you might be
thinking you know why is that such a big
deal
well there's a pin on this knight on f6
and if the knight on d7 were to take
back suddenly would be undefending
the bishop on c5 so it's just adding an
extra defender to this bishop so the
knight on d7 is free to move to f6
if need be because moves like knight e4
uh or potentially on the horizon
yes and well h6 would be a big threat
for black right because
then you remove the defender of the e3
pawn and that punk can be taken with
check
so h6 is the simple threat how do we
deal with that and maybe we have to
protect this e3 pawn
but if you play move like queen e2
you're walking into a new pin that could
be awkward knight c4 looks strong
because you protect e3 and uh you also
open the d file for your pieces but i'm
already looking at knight to b6
let's trade off knights let's try to get
that e3 pawn
and i feel like white's pawn structure
is just worse here
yeah knight to knight b6 it looks like
maybe i'd consider knight d6 there i
thought actually white was gonna play
knight e4
hitting the bishop and taking advantage
of the pin the move h6 we were talking
about
did happen and if bishop f4 he already
has to think about g5
e5 but he's saying look with my new move
knight c4 bishop d6 is the idea
there's an amazing line that i'm just
realizing based on your 94 move i think
that eric would have sacrificed his
queen with knight takes e4 so we can
show that in the analysis board
where just a move ago if uh instead of
knight c4
uh if knight e4 was played that would
have been a queen sack i believe
that would be a fun one bishop takes d8
and bishop takes e3
with the rook hanging on c1 ideas like
knight f2 in the position
you know bishop d8 later that would be a
fun one yeah that would have been really
cool but i think
levy he sniffed that one out he's like
this doesn't feel right
let's go for something a little more
solid and eric says no solidity for you
i'm pushing my pawn to e5 and guess what
that bishop on four
it's not going to be protecting this
pawn on e3 much longer if we trade
knights on e5
down goes up pawn e3 with check and that
rook on c1 is under attack it feels like
eric's about to win some material
yep e5 is a nice uh move that basically
everything is going to get clarified in
the center white's king is going to be a
little bit weak and bishop e3 we just
saw the
the line where you know the rook on c1
was threatened with the bishop and the
rook
what are you even supposed to do here um
asking the wrong guy uh the
video on f4 is under attack i was going
to say can you throw in b4 and he does
do that
but it feels like this take on f4 and
then maybe even take him
[Music]
capturing stuff and the pawn c5 at the
end of this is going to be hanging
right yeah i think that bishop takes b4
plays into levy's hands like that's the
intention of the move
um and wow what a what a poised move
there bishop b6 he says look that apon
is not able to move to a5 to continue
harassing me
the bishop is going to take the knight
on b5 in that case and if you take me
well there's so many things that are
going to be hanging in your position
after queen takes b6 the bishop's
trapped on f4
it's strapped in the center of the board
it has no three squares to go to
so what a restrained move by eric and
now does rook take c1 and e takes f4 you
win a piece
yeah just plain and simple um there's
nothing to do here
e3 is still weak still pinned i mean
that's the
one of the cleanest pieces you'll ever
see with knight g4 following this up
yeah and look at the clock five seconds
left for levy so he knows he's in
trouble eric
he's seizing the momentum here in this
match he won the first game
levy evened it now again with the black
pieces if eric can convert this it'll be
the third win with black in the match
yeah and this has got to be a conversion
four seconds up a full piece
uh i mean 50 seconds for you what more
could you ask for
yeah if you don't win this game that's
going to be really upsetting you know
you it's hard to come back from these
moments and we have seen this in
previous matches where a player just
really botches it
but here what's the best way because
knight c6 looks a little annoying now
this bishop takes e3 check after knight
c6
but you can also the queen takes a 5.
you can take that knight first
and then take on e3 so it's your just
for style points but
it looks like nobody's needing them here
b5 though will be played
and i think the the easiest is bishop b7
it looks it looks funny because you're
walking into maybe 97 check but the rook
was guarding that from e3
that's right now the trade of bishops
can happen the rook should probably go
on over to the a3 square there it goes
the b pawn can't move the 97
now knight b6 probably just scoops up
the a4 pawn
i believe so uh knight b6 now same idea
yes bringing both knights over and it's
a win on time but it was a win on the
board as well
exactly yeah and uh that's going to be a
recurring thing
i think the the time situation robert
it's constantly going to be
uh what looks like from the match so far
it's going to be levied down on time
but ever resourceful and you can just
never count them out
no you cannot and we get our halftime
break through the five minute plus one
second increment portion it is two to
one eric
players winning with the black pieces so
aman let me ask you something we we get
to
take a few minutes they get to prepare
look over lines
what do these players need to do to
start winning with the first move
image yeah it's funny i think that might
just be nerves
starting out um i actually haven't liked
the positions that
uh levy has gotten so far with the
catalan
it's it felt like uh eric was really
dictating the pace so
he might look to switch up his opening
we know he's a very accomplished london
system player as well like
these guys can play a bunch of different
openings uh it happens when you stream a
lot
you often experiment so i think that we
might see some openings uh being changed
when we come back
yeah i think they need to play a little
more solidly they're allowing black way
too much activity in these positions and
kings getting unsafe and things of that
nature but we'll see we'll be back in a
few minutes for more action from this
gotham chest i am rosen i am now gm
speechless championship match brought to
you by chess.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we returned ready for more
five-minute plus one second increment
blitz amman the players have
gotten the time to have a breather they
can stretch a little bit say
the nerves all right i know that we were
playing we were giving each other
chances
but now that a couple games are underway
what do you think
what can the players do differently how
do you see this match continuing
yeah i think uh so far what we've seen
is a lot of time pressure
and it's a tough thing to adjust to
because it's sort of stylistic you
either are a person who gets a long time
or you're not
but i think that levy if it continues
the way that we've seen so far
he might quickly identify that as sort
of like a lose condition like something
that he just simply has to change
or has to fix we saw him do a lot better
um at playing under time pressure he
turned around an entire game in
beautiful fashion
got right back in the match but going
forward i think he's going to have to
pick openings that he can play a little
bit quicker at the beginning
so that you know eric rosen isn't sort
of playing an offbeat line and sort of
knows the entire
opening and gets a one to two minute
time advantage for no reason
that's true and here we see a karo khan
and another exchange so
generally speaking this is seen as a
very solid position where
there are not as many tactical lines and
if levy goes for this e5 push again
he'll be left with the isolated queen
pawn so it looks like eric plays h3
which is thematic taking away anything
to g4
and that's already a big difference
between this and the previous game
yep you can tell like players are going
to use these brakes for different
reasons sometimes you don't want to look
at any chest during the break
the best thing for you might just be to
you know take drink relax
uh calm yourself down and some players
like to hop right on the the computer
check their analysis
and say look we might be playing this
line the whole match it's worth it for
me to check on some of the main lines
and h3
looks like an improvement that he came
back with and he's already coming out
very quickly
look he's got more time than he started
with robert yeah and levi has already
spent 40 seconds and
this is a better version of what we saw
in game two and the reason why
instead of having a pawn on f3 you have
a knight on f3 and your pawn's on h3 so
there are those dark square problems
you still have the blockade against this
pawn on d5 and this is how you tend to
play now black's position isn't that bad
i don't want to make it sound like
levy's done anything wrong he has not
it's a standard position
i just have a strong preference
stylistically of playing against the
isolated queen pawn because you need
activity you have the e file is open the
c file is semi-open for your rooks but
you're a bit behind in
uh in terms of development white can
bring a rook in first and then bring the
bishop out and that pawn on d5
especially after bishop g5 oman
that feels like the pawn is quite weak
yeah and there's something about this
position i almost prefer it to the last
game that levy played with this opening
just having those two bishops sometimes
you can even
lose this pawn on d5 just get all the
open files maybe b5 bishop b7
the rook's come to come to the middle of
the board and yeah he plays h6 he's
saying look
bishop takes f6 i'm going to take back
and feel free to take my pawn on d5
all of a sudden it's going to be moves
after moves with tempo although the
problem is bishop f6 bishop 6
knight b4 you can actually try to win
that pawn with your knight
and that causes black more problems so
he instead retreats his bishop to h4
which is fine the bishop can go to g3 as
well
and you could take on f6 at some moment
but right now queen b6 levy
he's timing these moves very well
hitting this pawn on b2
yep and definitely after queen b6 i
think it's going to be a rook b1
consideration however
you mentioned it last time queen takes
b2 rook f to b1
and that is going to be a trapped queen
however rook e1 hits the bishop
if bishop c5 hitting f2 i mean the queen
watches over the knight on f6
yes and so now do you just play bishop
e6 which is not a move you
like to play because the knight wants to
blockade the pawn anyway and if your
bishop sitting on e6 you defend the pawn
and d5 but now your bishop on e6 is
under attack and then you have to think
is my opponent going to capture me there
so i think levy already has
a tough choice here he does play bishop
e6 and i'm looking at knight
f to d4 because i want my knight on c2
potentially go to e3 later
right um and i think there's there's an
interesting move i've been looking at
i'm not quite sure if it works but
knight e4
um giving up the e7 bishop for some sort
of queen f2
um shenanigans down there don't know if
it worked but
definitely looked a little bit
unnecessary in the position uh knight
d4c to d4
just played which means in general you
have to watch out for that b2 pawn now
that there is queen a3 to escape that's
right and your 94 idea that's actually
pretty interesting something that levy
if he gets time after
uh this series of games for the next
break he can look into that but that's
really deep into these
openings probably too far down the line
to think about too much but it's hard
move to play
because that bishop on e7 would have
been hanging but anyway that's behind us
the knights on d4 blocking that queen's
access to f2
but as you just said the pawn on b2 is a
problem so rookie 2 comes to mind
uh i don't really want to play rook a1
to b1 that feels like too
passive of a way to defend that pawn
whereas rook e2 a to e1
now we're talking getting my rooks onto
the open file
yeah rookie 2 rook 81 looks uh like the
best
uh way to do this because it also adds
pressure
on e6 and e7 those two bishops lined up
there
i'm actually kind of curious how black
is going to meet that it might be with
that move knight e4
now that the bishop is defended on e7 if
one of the hardest questions to answer
is do you take on e6 and i'm much more
likely to take on e6
when black's pawn is on h6 rather than
h7 because the g6
squares a little bit vulnerable but
instead eric does play the calm
the cool collective move rookie two and
his plan is
pretty natural right just rookie two
rookie one and for levi i think now is
the time to strike whether it's knight
to e4
there's also knight h5 which is just a
tricky move
trying to get your knight to f4 with the
fork but he needs to act because he
can't sit on this position much longer
yeah and i was just gonna say we we've
reached a middle game position
you can see the eval bar right around
the middle there knight h5 your move
played
knight f4 you have to watch out for it
but i think this is good from levi he's
keeping pace
you know the time is not an issue but we
have seen him just kind of randomly tank
about a minute in a regular position
like this
if he avoids that he can find moves you
know knight h5 look how quickly he
played that
it's a great move he just needs to trust
himself it's also a great realization
recognition that last one was rookie e2
so something has changed knight h5 if
that rook on e1 would not be a
particularly good move
but because you have the fork available
to you it creates this tactical
uh possibility and now the bishops are
staring each other down bishop takes e7
is a blunder because of knight f4 and
knight takes e2
with check before taking that bishop
back so i think that
white needs to move the queen and
probably queen
d2 but queen c2 is also a move i
don't know what you want to pick yeah
the interesting thing about queen
you know d2 to watch the f4 square is
that
levy might just sidestep next move play
bishop d6 control the f4 square
say look your bishop on h4 is doing
absolutely nothing now there's no
there's no pin there's nothing to hit
and you can't even go back to g3 because
i've got that covered
that's a good call and he takes an e6
which covers the f4 square
so at least that's protected against
but what if i just take back on e6 which
i have to do f takes e6
and then knight f4 is a renewed threat
the rook on f8 is very happy to get that
semi-open file
and there could be tactics as well with
like a rook takes f3 at some point
there's lots of renewed threats in that
case remember if the bishop goes back to
g3 it's always a free piece as well
uh because the queen on b6 is pinning
that f2 pawn you mentioned ideas like
rook takes f3
might not work exactly here but keep
that in mind as a way to remove the
knight from defending
the bishop on h4 so yeah i mean you just
called it knight f4
to cap it off there are so many threats
here that uh
eric has to deal with and levy is now up
on time and
seems to be taking over the the game
slowly if
eric had a bit of time you know knight
e5 knight g6 taking over those
vulnerable light squares that would be
nice
you just don't have that time knight h5
was such a good move by levy
and queen d4 i think bishop c5 knight f4
to follow bring all of my pieces in for
the attack
levy he's doing well on the clock and
doing better on the board
so i think that this is his chance to
even the match definitely bishop c5 is
very very natural here um
i guess there is a you know a world for
queen takes d4
um keep in mind queen d4 pawn d4 rook
takes f3
white's gonna throw in bishop takes on
uh e7 or
even maybe a tricky rook takes e6 in
that position so
um for example queen takes take with the
pawn let's say something like
rook takes f3 i mean this is a wild
calculation but it's probably uh
something that these players are
considering robert
ryan your bishop takes e7 was important
i would say instead of taking on f3
which loses the bishop
and then it's a knight against a bishop
the bishop not great the knight can hop
around the board
but that's we'll save that for those
classical books that we read about we're
going to get something more tactical
here with bishop five i know it
i i'm sure like especially after a long
think like this you almost
have to keep that that bishop in play
there we go we do see bishop
c5 stylistically i think that suits levy
even more
use that open f file and is it going to
be knight f4 here or
just knight back to f6 knight f4 played
and the rook needs to scoot on over you
need to keep an eye on the f2 pawn i'd
say
so rook to d2 and i'm already looking at
moving h5
for black the point being that queen on
g4 is running out of squares quite
quickly
it's pretty dangerous position so where
is that queen going after hrv i guess
you have queen g3
but then bishop d6 renewing the threat
of a discovery against that queen
and it really is running out of options
yeah and it you know if i
even show something like queen to g5
rook f5 is one of the ideas
bishop d6 we see that queen nearly
getting trapped there
and you know ideas like knight e2 eric
just can't develop that rook on f1 or a1
robert
and levy played h5 so he's seen all the
tactics
and right now it's about even the clock
levy a little bit ahead but his position
is so much better but i will say now
that we're getting into that bullet
stretch of this game mistakes do happen
much more commonly so you think you have
a winning tactic and you
miss the fourth move down the line and
all of a sudden things go wrong i think
levy has this he's been in control
for a large part of the game right now
but it's still tricky especially when
you're pawn's on h5 and your king side's
a little bit open
yeah and i'm i'm wondering how how we're
supposed to stop this robert it's almost
like king h1
is one of the only moves just get in the
corner and strangely enough this knight
maybe doesn't have any
completely winning moves that's true
king each one and then you're so
frustrated as black because
i have to have a winning move and then
you have to realize wait there's no win
on this turn but my position is better
because my pieces are coordinated really
well
so what that move is right now i don't
know w what piece needs to be improved
should i put my queen somewhere else
should i play e5 but e5 has risk because
then the d5 pawn is looser
not an easy situation right now for
black despite having the about
evaluation
lead as we see on screen here it just
isn't that easy to play
not at all i actually like the move e5
it's risky but i think the position
almost calls for e5 e4
knight d3 uh sync that knight in and
then just just play from there at the
end of the day
you can't calculate a perfect variation
here it's frustrating enough that
there's no wind on the spot
i think just mobilize the center and you
know it's frustrating because look levi
spent a lot of time and now we're at
even time and i saw the eval bar it went
back up better for white all of a sudden
knight d4 hits the work with tempo
and this is exactly what happens in a
bullet stretch of a game
yeah and queen g6 after a night move
like knight e2 keeping my queen g6
it's gonna hit the rook on e8 there's so
many things happening and moves are
flying in
quick as a flash now robert okay and if
i play that pawn is pins you're not
actually threatening the knight on d4
maybe there's a move thrown he plays
bishop g5 for that reason and look at
levy quickly
renewing the discovery against the queen
queen for it now take on f4 take on h5
is possible in some variations le'veon
in eight seconds he's now down on time
maybe bishop ba queen d6 an idea that go
for h2 mate he doubles rooks on the f
file and now
we're gonna have to see eric getting
under 10 seconds this is going to be a
wild finish
it is radiation you have to play the
quickly the h5 punting look at queen h6
g5 g5 will trap the queen that's a win
on the spot he has to play f3 it's not a
move you want to play and no
replay he's threatening g5 again queen
he won he freed up the square and all of
a sudden levy's thinking 2.7 seconds
the queen comes back to e1 and now queen
b1 and look at this it's turning around
yeah bishop f4 and queen g3 though
he wins in exchange this is not over
though bishop f4
keep that e3 pawn queen d5 king h8 oh my
gosh but you have the palm but rook to
d1 take over that open file you have
rooks use them
and queen somewhere are you just going
to figure out where to knock him out in
1.3 seconds both of these players are
just
almost losing on the spot queen d4 check
rook d7 coming up
yep queen d5 check queen careful queens
wait trade every one of me
because robert all he had to do was play
queen takes f7 with a check
queen f7 check he needed to take the
rook but he took it the wrong way and
what
a move by levy rosman and let's show
that finish one more time let's bring up
the
uh analysis board there because you
needed to trade the queens off you saw
before it happened that queen b won
checkmate but queen takes f7
wins for white just look at that eval
bar it goes after rook f7 all the way up
queen takes f7
needed to be played here black would be
forced to trade because it's a check
but the wrong piece captured first and
that's why order matters in chess look
at that eval bar
all the way down robert and queen b1
found by levy wow and that can turn the
entire match around for levy here he
played a very good game he was alert he
was
pressing forward and he started off very
well on the clock
then things got out of hand and well i
hate to say i called it but we were
getting that point where he's getting
the bullet and all of a sudden it's
difficult to find the knockout you're
getting frustrated
you play a little bit slowly and then
eric was timely he struck back with 96
winning exchange
and finally in a pure time scramble it
was
levy on top there just finding queen bee
one track a lot of credit to both of
those players after a
hard fought game and wait d5 is a pawn
sacrifice
yeah i was gonna say this is actually a
well-known uh ponzac
in this line um the move e3 i don't
think is very good because of it
i mean it's not winning on the spot or
anything but it's just a nice way to
get developed and uh usually black is
pretty happy to
to get that move in yeah the one
downside in black's position is the e5
pawn a little bit loose and that knight
on d5 now is not defended but if you
take knight takes e5 the bishop
recaptures and the queen opens up to
that knight that would be a blunder by
white
even though it looks like you might be
winning a pawn yeah and i think both
players are are going to try to solve
their
their problems here just castling bishop
e6 now a move that always
hurts bishop e6 it moves like knight g5
and that's what makes me think of e4
and play quickly by levy if pawn takes
on e4 we're gonna see the knight jump
into g5
hitting the bishop and then looking to
take back on e4 maybe with a piece
keep in mind there's queen h5 check
queen b3 so many ideas i like white's
position after e4
and part of the problem with this
opening is that knight on d5 it went
knight c6
knight b4 knight takes d5 that takes
time and the king is still in the center
white's king is castled and
black's position's a bit flimsy here so
knight g5 coming as you've been talking
about
the light squares are very vulnerable
and i think that eric he kind of has to
just say all right this doesn't look
good
but let me take on e4 and when you go
knight g5 i'll just play queen e7 and
you'll take my bishop i won't be happy
about it
but at the very least i'll have the
ability to castle next and i'm not down
any material
yeah that's a great point and already in
the tank here uh
is rosen although the time's actually
even it looks like levy was taking his
time earlier with that tricky d5 move so
both players investing in the opening we
actually have seen the opening phase of
this match robert has really taken a
long time
i think that is partly because rosen
does play
so many tricky sidelines it's just his
style that i think both players in
general are going to be investing time
in the opening
because levy wants to make sure that
he's not misstepping in any of these
offbeat lines and it's the first time
we've seen white with a good position on
the opening because we've had four
wins by black and the openings have
looked good for the black pieces this is
the first
real advantage with the white pieces
that i can recall
absolutely and and it's a very real
advantage um after knight
g5 i mean it already comes to question
are we playing bishop g8 to keep the
bishop that's the move that comes to
mind that's the first
instinct but it's not clear that you can
get away with that because you're not
going to be castling kingside there
give so much time to your opponent right
so queen e7
eric says i have to i'll give up that
bishop take it my queen takes at least
my center is protected i can try to
castle queen side
and if you take on e4 with the pawn your
bishop on g2 could actually
be a bystander to plenty of the action
in this game so you prefer to take with
the bishop on e4
but that leaves that pawn on d3 as an
isolated pawn and that could be a
problem in and of itself so
it's not an easy decision for levy
either
definitely um i think there's like queen
a4 queen takes e4 if you want to play
that way
black won't be too upset though to play
um c6 and maybe long castle or
short castle there so i think levy is
just
definitely better it looks like he does
want to play queen a4 and maybe take
back with the queen on e4
another situation where it's clear that
white is better
but a few moves from now that advantage
can go away and
in part it's because this decision right
now you have three pieces
all those captured in e4 look pleasant
for white but then you say
is it really that bad for black you said
castle king side why not give that seve
open file maybe my bishop will come to
c5 at some moment and i can attack your
pawn on f2 and all of a sudden i like my
isolated pawn e5 just like
the iqp we had in other positions look
at queen b3
threatening the b7 pawn threatening to
go d takes e4 and perhaps black says
all right i'll give you b7 and i'm
taking you on d3 and now we get a wild
tactical game
yeah it makes me question like what
what's the call your bluff move
is it pawn takes on d3 queen b7 short
castle
queen takes c6 e4 and just saying look
i'll take the entire center
you get my entire queen side that center
if it falls apart it's gg
but if he hangs on to that that could be
levy spoiling his advantage
although i like what eric just did
because while e takes d3 could have
worked
look at that bishop on g2 not the
happiest bishop that we've seen
especially when you have two bishops
advantage
a queen trade not so bad for black your
rooks are connected can take over the d
files so i think all things considered
eric is very happy to get to this
position
out of the opening where it looked like
he could lose tactically in a few moves
absolutely um i think this game is going
to come down to
the dark squares if this bishop manages
you know to put itself on d4 for example
it's going to be looking at the f2 pawn
the b2 pawn and it's going to be very
very strong but bishop e3 that's why he
played h3 keep that move in mind he
didn't just play for no reason knight g4
would have been the same annoyance as
knight g5 earlier in this game
attacking the bishop but played h3
stopped it now he takes over
this important important diagonal and
that that's why i think that
levy's doing well here and he does it
with tempo that palm a7 is now under
attack
if the rook run a8 so if that rook on f8
went to d8
do you play your idea bishop c7 bishop
b6 and try to trade off those dark
square bishops
but now the pawn a7 is under attack so
you don't have time
to just make a random move otherwise
white will capture so if you play a6
then a bishop plants itself on b6 and
takes over the dark squares there
that's not so bad for black and a bishop
trade the darts are bishop trade could
be
nice because that bishop on g2 isn't in
the game but
giving up those holes on the queen side
isn't exactly appealing
absolutely the the dark squares here are
gonna shape the game and
levy up a minute on the clock it's like
where have we seen
this before well not in this match so
far robert white has a good position
and levy's up a minute on the clock yeah
and eric
has really been struggling in this game
and it's because
he did kind of the opening surprise and
then levy just
parried it off really well and now eric
trying to find the precise moves
you need to make the good moves quickly
not the best move slowly we
always say this and right now bishop c7
is played giving up that pawn in a7
that [ __ ] what do you think robert
basically it comes down to do you have
it in you to take it because
i think we can all look at this pawn and
say that's greedy but
it's takeable yeah i think you should
capture it and
what eric's really relying on is not a
bishop trap i think he wants to trade
the bishops and he says
i'll give you that outside rook pawn if
i trade the bishops i'll take over the
dark squares in particular the d4 square
it takes a while for a knight to get
there but if that knight could go f6 to
e6 and into d4
then we're talking yeah uh still
a crucial decision because that's a way
to hang the match right there you know
what i mean or at least hang this game
bishop a7 if you miscalculate something
believe me what he's looking at is
bishop a7 b6
and then queen takes c6 and you know
like there follows maybe a rook d6
or something like that and that bishop
does stay locked on a7 for
longer than feels comfortable and i'm
sure that levy
doesn't believe in it he knows that he
can take the pawn a7 he's checking
double checking unfortunately quadruple
checking because he gets himself in some
time trouble
but he does take the pawn so he makes
the right decision he spent a minute and
four seconds
to figure it out but um eric had spent a
minute and 17 seconds
on his move so both players spent a lot
of time
and eric just goes rook 8 i guess the a2
pawn can be captured but
bishop c5 with tempo 8 pawn is saved
and that totally worked out for levy
time invested
and paid off immediately that you wonder
about the similarities between chess and
poker well robert that was called a
bluff
bishop c7 i think eric rosen knew that
pawn could be taken but
just hoping that the the calculations
would scare off levy but
you know levy says all right let's go
you want to calculate that i'm right
there with
you and i believe he calculated it very
well let's see if he can convert
his one pawn advantage as we mentioned
those dark square bishops now being
traded off
fantastic decision by eric you're down a
pawn you realize that my knight can
outclass a bishop
especially that light square bishop so
if you trade the bishops levy says no
don't want any part of that but now the
f2 pawn
so rook f8 the problem is not solved
because that bishop can plant itself on
d4 he plays knight f6
still that bishop can come to d4 and how
is white going to make progress you have
an extra pawn
but it's this f2 pawn that's really
where your extra pawn is right now
you're not moving that because i can get
your king in trouble and so
it's not so clear how to proceed i like
that decision by levy i would go f4 here
and he's played it
king h2 just like get the king out of
the way i know that i can't trade these
bishops so you know what i'm going to
give you this great d4 square we talked
about it earlier
and i think bishop h4 could be played
here and he saves the bishop g5 not
possible because the f4 pawn is right
there
but you're not going to take on e5 and
then the bishop takes back on e5
and that's a great square so in comes
the queen say please take my knight and
f6 i don't mind
opening my king because you don't have
pieces to attack me and it's your king
on h2 on that dark square that can get
in some trouble
and it's tough decision after tough
decision for levy right now do you play
f5 that closed down the position he says
no
bishop f3 let's attack the queen you're
gonna drop back the g6
and now do i play f5 that's f5 with
tempo that's always a little bit more
enticing
i think queen queen b3 i was actually
wondering on the last move was it gonna
happen because it sort of makes the move
queen h5
look a little questionable oh and now if
you don't trade queens
is black gonna take on f4 and say hey
you take with your pawn your king is not
feeling so safe
i would take on f4 i'm down to pawn but
i'm going for your kick ef4 g for bishop
e3
threading rook d2 when he plays bishop
v3 first rook d2 is the threat
yep it's got to be rook well you feel
like it's got to be rook d1 but
hey that that pawn can now be taken
there's an e5 flurry
you know in the position but i just
don't think it quite works for levy
no because you can take on d1 and then
move your knight you got out of the pin
by trading
and this is why i didn't like f4 your
king is exposed you're creating threats
for black
now black has all of this out seven
seconds for white you gotta go you gotta
now knight d5
your pawn forward defend f63 is a big
threat because the rook on f1 is not
defended
the king is in a big trouble here f
takes g3
king g2 and then bishop c2 g5 just
trapped the bishop there
there's still some tricks here though
queen f6 is a solid move
g takes h4 okay that's going to be in
there queen h7 that was sneaky though
and just rookie yeah the fisherman e3 is
protected
so queen e7 here pick up the pawn and
the king on jade
can live to see another day this is not
gonna be enough um
and you know he's gonna try here but uh
i don't think we're gonna see anything
other than
eric rosen converting this position he's
got an extra piece and a pawn to boot
what a wild game it looked like levy had
a big advantage and then
eric played good defense and the
position opened up unfavorable terms for
levy
now eric can just push his f pawn he
puts his king in he's trying to go for a
checkmate if he got a rook p5 bishop f2
mate so that's why the king ran away
and now his f-pawn can start running
yeah and this
uh you know it's levy who has the one
second you know in rook f5
trying for something you know hoping for
f3 pre-move or something like that
good try that was a good try and we
still have
16 minutes 45 seconds left in this
longest time control
and i'm not sure who prefers to play
more games because it has felt very back
and forth
black has won all five games okay
so maybe they should start playing a3 on
the first move and try to play
with just hand the move over i agree
because even with that opening advantage
that we saw there robert
it just can't break the curse that black
is winning every single game it
okay d4 a fun position with white is it
gonna matter well
let's find out robert can white finally
win a game in this match
and this variation is interesting i'm
not quite sure why eric went away
from the positions he was getting with
the iqp that isolated queen pawn
i thought they were pleasant for white
but perhaps eric didn't feel like they
were in his comfort zone
and instead we're getting a more open
position look at this the bishop on d3
is open now the bishop d6 of course is
open
knight takes d4 there could be bishop
takes h2 check as a possibility with
queen h4 to follow that's a known
tactical sequence
which means that the pawn d4 could be
potentially untouchable
yeah and i i always wonder in positions
like this uh if rosen is really planning
to take it back right away or
if he's sort of going for something more
attacking knight takes d4
looks tempting is it worth saving this
bishop uh something like c5
you can already keep the extra pawn but
i think that might be exactly what rosen
is looking for
it reminds me of these openings where
freaking exactly what move it is but
it's like the italian with an early d4
and a
sacrifice we try to like bishop g5 and
give up the pawn and go for an attack
that shouldn't work out with proper play
but it's always scary and instead levy
says i don't want to deal with that let
me just develop my pieces
i'm doing fine i'm up a pawn right now
my bishop pins your knight so you can't
even get the d4 pawn but i would
probably play h3 and just
try to get the bishop pair yep yeah h3
um looks like a good move to start with
uh no matter what you know if the bishop
goes to h5 you deal with that after
knight takes dc because bishop h7 check
of queen takes d6
so you have to take on f3 wow
what a move yeah we can show that for
everybody just what a
nice little tactic yeah so knight takes
c6
queen takes d6 i mean that's a move you
pretty much pre-move nearly
um here and then knight g5 check and
queen takes
g4 and hey you pick that up the g4 pawn
is still
loose in the position there's still
ideas like queen to the h file and queen
h7 mate
yes and it would be even material so i
think that's what levy's trying to
figure out here
because he can give the h7 pawn or he
can take on f3 and then give up
two bishops keep his material and say
i have the knights and extra pawn but
you have these bishops my king could
still be vulnerable
i would i wouldn't want to give the
bishop but i don't want to give the h7
pawn so he does
take on f3 and i think that's the best
choice and do you think there's also
a little bit of ego like you don't want
to let the guy play bishop to h7 on you
you're like oh i see the tactic i can't
let him uh do me like that on chess tv
yeah that's probably part of it you know
there are what uh 18 000 people here on
twitch and
you know more on youtube and elsewhere
on chess tv everyone's watching so
i know bishop h7 for you and instead we
have
this position what is white's follow-up
though because how do you really
start making creating pressure that's
the thing you can get away
with you know having the bishops and
that sounds good but then you have to
prove it like
where are you going from here the proof
is always the hard part i think in
general
you know move like bishop d2 or a3 is
almost needed uh
i'm a little concerned about knight d7
knight e5 or knight b4 in general taking
these pieces out of the way knight f6
looks so natural but
i think he he wanted that to follow up
with bishop g5 and
try to get a rook lift maybe i think
eric's just relying on
counter play and activity and even
though knight b to d7
that final night is out the rooks are
connected black should be happy up upon
you just see these bishops and you have
to concern yourself if i ever play h6
is he just gonna sack that bishop on h6
and rip with my king and so how do i
yeah how do i shield myself but the
simple answer is probably move your
queen away because under attack then
bring your rook to e8
go with the open file and just play it
slowly be deliberate you don't have to
rush any decisions here
absolutely um keep in mind queen d5 i
know it sounds crazy but it's hitting
that a2 pawn so
if all the rooks go to e8 we might see a
situation where you can almost take that
and just grab
a2 and say look you know i prove your
advantage
i like that rook 81 queen takes a2 is a
possibility
and if i am eric i'm probably ready to
give that up like i'll play b3 trap your
queen over there for a while and try to
get some kind of quick play
but you are down one pawn going down two
not ideal
yeah that's a good point queen d5 just a
nice centralizing movement life is just
putting the question
back to eric we see the time situation
b3 played because
hey he saw that a pawn and let's keep in
mind
levy actually took the pawn on e7 so i
think rosen is probably thinking
i don't think i can bluff him twice in
the same match
and once again black has a good position
now the opening
up the engine right we see the
evaluation bar it agrees
and the thing about b3 which is tricky
is there's some bishop c4
not to be so afraid of but at some
moment the f7 square could be a target
so
i think that's why levy's taking his
time but rook fte that's
the sort of the obvious move to him but
he's trying to say maybe i switch my a
rook over maybe that's the precise way
to go
and the only downside of playing 88 is
if i get bishop d6 if i can
remove your queen then your rook on f8
is trapped over there so there is
something to figure out
yeah i was thinking another like main
idea that sometimes black goes for is
queen h5
with the idea queen g3 queen g4 now
don't know if we want to do that exactly
in this moment but it's actually a way
to force the queens
off the board for sure and when you're
up upon you always want to be looking
for ways to possibly do that
there's a great tactical sequence right
now bishop e5 queen e5
rook 81 and yeah the queen of d6
afterwards and you can play the move
rookie seven i've actually experienced
this in a game
where my opponent has done that to me
and i was shocked but the point is that
the queen takes e7
bishop takes h7 and the knight can't
capture you back so
someone has done this not in this exact
position but i have faced this before
and i've stored that in the memory bank
of hey wait a sec that knight on f6 is
pinned
and it would only be a draw in that case
but that's just the type of thing that
scares you you know if you're
calculating yeah and
like i said i missed it and it was in
much bigger consequences in an online
game so it wasn't that big a deal as a
blitz game
but i remember being like what in the
world oh
that's sick so i've kept that in mind
since then knight g6 is a great choice
by levy they're just hitting the queen
and the
bishop and you're forcing off one of the
pair of bishops so it looks like it's a
good trade
yeah the bishops get significantly
weaker when
you divide them in half uh two bishops
down to one is a big deal actually that
pawn is going to move up to c5
defend the pawn on d4 and we've been
talking about this extra pawn that that
levy's had the whole game well he's
still got it and now it becomes more and
more meaningful
well now it's on d3 it's this dark
square bishop light square
on d3 rook d8 coming and hard to see how
you pile up pressure you can play rook
d2 but then the knight comes into e4
he starts with bishop e3 he wants to
play bishop d4 cutting off the queen and
the pawn but then black has
the c5 move to say get your bishop out
of here that pawn is staying on the
board
yeah and keep in mind that bishop might
take that pawn on a7 if you've seen it
before robert
i'm just gonna be calling out uh those
apons from now on that'll be my wait
wait wait can we can we take it
[Laughter]
oh my goodness no no we please no this
can't actually happen
wait but can we okay
now i'm actually a little serious that
pawn is under attack
can we just steal that pawn
okay he's not it's too much yeah it's
too much but now he is threatening to
take that pawn with his queen
and he cut off the queen from the d3
pawn so if you trade on d4
i just take back and then i will win the
d3 pawn next move so this is a really
good move by eric
although bishop takes a7 hats begs the
question is that pawn really hanging
it does that time is even queen d4
played there's
always an idea to just move that queen
but let's say queen f5
then we're dead serious queen takes a7
has to happen
um if we trade that bishop takes back i
think it is
you know reasonable to play something
like e6 keep in mind that if you just
grab that pawn on d3 there is going to
be c5
that's going to be a pin from the rook
on d8 to the rook on d3 so
white can't is or is not threatening
rook takes d3 in the current position
he could have captured with the pawn on
d4 which would have allowed him to
capture the pawn on d3 next
but that would be something in a
capablanca game where black just crushes
because it's a terrible bishop on the
dark squares
and an isolated pawn so that's why eric
took with the bishop
and he's up time levy down to 45 seconds
he is
better here that's for sure he's up a
pawn and as you said c5 will be the
response that we're taking
d3 but he doesn't have time so he needs
to move quickly
yeah bishop d4 and b6 is natural are we
gonna see b4
to sort of counteract that c5 move or
are we gonna
are we gonna maybe see f3 uh king out
basically
rosen is trying to take that pawn in the
best way possible he he wants to take it
and have an even structure
he plays the move f3 he can't have
everything though robert um he has to
focus on winning that pawn back at all
yeah the reason why i didn't like b4 for
white is i don't want to even think
about that black pawn game c4 to protect
the past pawn
so if he keeps the pawn on b3 even if
you get c5 you're not getting
c4 in so right now in knight hi i like
that move and rook takes d3 there's
still c5 walking into a pin
don't do that so king f2 makes sense but
now that knight can come into f4
yeah knight f4 and i mean the bishop is
going to be attacked by
some sort of knight e6 and still rook
takes d3 not possible g5 played
and are we going to see like rook e1 uh
b4
all these moves come to mind i think
it's still a very tense game levy is
actually the one
getting low on time here he is 22
seconds and rookie one there could be a
rookie seven out of nowhere
and the bishop on d4 is staring at the
g7 pawn so you have to watch out for
that
and rookie one also there's a rookie
five move hitting the g5 pawn
so rookie one played 20 seconds not for
levy you got to go did you play g4 here
no he says let's go to c5
and i played e5 well e3 was also good
but that knight
has nowhere to go i'll take it pretty
much wherever it uh runs to
yeah uh i guess in this position i would
probably look the stick of rook on e8
um to challenge that uh that e file now
c4 happens and rook d5 just looks silly
it goes back to d7 rookie 3 rook fd8 at
least you're holding on that pawn but
the problem is your knight can't get
back in i will take your knight
and blockade your pawn so i actually
think that white has
very good chance to hold i would
probably start with rook d2 here
i don't even want to think about your
pawn pushing but if your pawn does push
i guess i can actually team up on it
more easily so he does play g4
he probably will take this knight no
matter where it goes but seven seconds
eight seconds okay he moved and rook e5
without using a rookie four instead
it's almost like a bullet move where you
get them pre-moving g5 or something
because ricky [ __ ] doesn't look as good
no and now i would play
king e2 probably and just go near the
pawn h4 all right making sure that black
can't push the pawns
now king e2 but there's always rook c3
keep in mind like rick c1 threat and he
can't take d2 without losing f3 oh rook
takes f4 that's a pawn
i'll grab that one or take that f4 maybe
rook e8
to follow then rookie four right i just
try to trade off some rooks and get my
king d2
but a4 that's nice you're trying to
break down white's pawn structure but if
a b rook takes rook takes d2
he gets the pass pawn and now it's even
material yeah and 1.6 seconds for levy i
mean
is someone going to flag this game it
really feels like it oh i got 1.8 he
barely got that move up three seconds
for eric he plays hr that's a good move
pawn chain rook five another group of
keep your pieces defended now the
seventh rank is scary
pawn goes down rook b7 rook d7 to follow
rook d6 here
probably wins g6 i think that's king
this king can come into the position
king
f6 kg5 king f4 careful of that king oh
my gosh king takes g4 whose past pawn is
better
i don't know don't play rook g3 g6 is
hanging rookie two's almost mate though
yeah it's almost majority players rook
d2 and rookie are going for a game
0.4 seconds how is that even possible oh
they go with 0.1 seconds barely
is possible i wasn't gonna fight you and
now levy's up a point
that's me we'll get one's mate oh my
goodness
oh my gosh
someone was gonna lose that game eric is
so he just didn't react and levy just
like what just happened this is
ridiculous
and it's an even match and white still
has not
even scored a half point it is six
nothing
for the players the black pieces in a
3-3 match overall that makes no sense
when white makes the first move every
engine that you could ever
see in the world is going to say yeah
white has a slight advantage after e4
and yet we've seen no wins with the
white pieces this is crazy
uh somehow right now you know black is
just cracked i mean they know something
that we don't
robert because uh some of them about the
opening choices in this match
uh i mean it's almost like you get the
black pieces and you're feeling more
confident
and i'm just looking at the players levy
kind of looks like he's struggling for
breath after what was a crazy finish
and eric's looking like he's making
decisions at the grocery store he just
doesn't react like
he's just there hanging out like does he
not feel the pain of just losing that
game
by getting checkmated in a two-rook
position i am
just out of words and eric is just
calmly biting into his
hoodie and moving on i think that's
about as nervous as
you'll see him get you know the classic
you know yellow
hoodie collar bite is uh that's the most
emotion you'll you'll get out of uh
eric rosen as again you pointed it out
he's already just focused on this next
match whereas
levy it's like you can almost see the
the
the cold war flashbacks from last game
in his eyes
and for eric you should be happy he's
got the black piece in this game but
actually i like white's position
because of this [ __ ] don't say that
robert i i you know i
tend to think that white has good
chances here but after this 94 move it's
funny that's the tempting move but i
think white should have probably started
with c5 because
look at the knight coming right back to
d2 that's saying f5 could have come now
at least i'm attacking the pawn on e5 so
f5 doesn't work
but black can probably play in bishop d6
or queen d6 or something
to defend the pawn he does play bishop
d6 and the setup is solid
white is still trying to play c5 and
advance the knight but that d3 pawn
that's always a potential weakness
yes this classic position so you give up
the bishop pair two bishops for black
but
by doing that then they don't have six
it's so instrumental in controlling the
center especially the light squares e4
and d5
you give that up well now look knight e4
the other knight maybe can cycle back to
d2 we might see the c
pawn push followed by knight d2 to c4
and all of a sudden every piece for
white is getting involved here robert
that's true and then c6 it's it's
supposed to be a good piece it's
developed
but often you want the knight on d7 to
go into like c5 and try to make progress
there and
right now knight after d2 you called it
the bishop on g2 watch out on that
diagonal there could be some problems
here and c5 for white and then knight to
c4 and all of a sudden those knights are
getting into the game
the bishop is thriving on the long
diagonal and black is in
some trouble there trying to defend the
position
and bishop g6 i was about to say f5
such a big idea in this position and you
know a well-timed e4
for black is usually what makes it break
this position for either side
g4 you might look at that move and say
you know what the heck is levy up to but
this is a positional idea taking control
of f5 and we actually might see this
knight on d2
uh either reroute f1 to g3 or maybe the
knight on e4 dropping back to g3 it's
all about controlling the light squares
which is why levy gave up his dark
square bishop for a knight
and the main drawback of course is the
dark squares there so if you
move that knight away from d2 i will
consider playing bishop takes e4 and
then bishop g5 very quickly get my
bishop into f4
cause your king you know some problems
over there and c5
is a good move it takes up space that
knight can go into the c4 square maybe
into b6 or d6
so levy has things going on for him but
i would even consider rook a5 saying are
you
are you gonna get away with knight to c4
maybe that c5 pawn is a target
i guess it might not work out in that
immediate position but rook a5 that rook
lift is actually thematic
yeah it's either going to be rook a5 or
rook c8 but brook a5 makes more sense
because you don't want to just drop the
a4 pawn now that you put it there you
can't just drop it for nothing
king h8 speaks to the fact that rosen
might be feeling like hey
white's doing all the you know has all
the ideas here i have to do something
king h8 says
you know at some point the move f5 makes
some sense now i want to get off this
diagonal
and he takes an e4 because he says the
c5 pawn is no longer defended the g5
square i can bring my bishop there or
if i take on c5 first my queen can get
out over to g5 or h4 the problem with
this
is there are going to be times where
bishop takes c6 knight takes e5
tactically work out for what this is uh
i think
it seems very uh fortunate that it is
working out because
after bc6 knight takes e5 rook is
threatening
the c5 bishop and hang on that king on
h8 does not look very smart right now
because knight takes e5 also now
threatens
knight takes f7 so you have the move
queen d5 and that queen is a hero
protecting literally everything the c5
bishop the c6 pawn
and the f7 square while attacking the
knight on e5 so
you have that saving grace but you're
right iman that you wish that you could
put that king just hey no one's looking
king's back to jail if you're playing
the hustlers in the park you there
quickly put the king back into g8 and
then make a different move and here
queen definitely
only option and isn't this very tricky
queen d5
knight takes f7 king g8 looks like a
really fun move to play because
you almost say look that knight on f7
stranded after king g8 it's like wait a
minute i thought
i was the one with the white pieces
doing the tactic could we see this flip
around right away knight f7 looks like a
very reasonable move to play
yeah what a shocking move king g8 would
be and the thing about this position is
even if i had to take your knight and go
down a pawn
you wish that pawn speaking of sliding
pieces could that pawn go back maybe one
square or two back to g3 or g2
because your king is going to be open
for the rest of the game but that is an
amazing
thing to see iman with knight f7 king g8
and your knight has nowhere to go
yeah it's such a funny move and i think
maybe levy's starting to realize that
now because you almost go into this
thinking okay the guys king's on h8 with
the rook pressuring c5 i simply have
knight takes f7
winning upon queen you know has to take
rook takes c5
but knight f7 king g8 and suddenly it's
your knight who's getting trapped
and we could see black win yet another
game in this series and the thing is if
you move your knight back casually like
knight c4
black says i'm gonna get rid of my back
rank problems with an attack with h5
ripping your king side open and then my
bishop later can come to the
bh2 diagonal my queen's coming over to
the king side to cause some threats
i don't like white's position all of a
sudden it felt like there was something
there
and then you go for the direct win of
material and it backfires because of
this
wonderful king j8 move that we've been
pointing out so this is a scary position
for levy
yeah and there's not an easy decision to
make here because
knight c4 as you mentioned there's
there's moves like h5 coming up the the
fact is the queen can't get out
and after knight f3 rook takes e1 as the
first move that comes to mind because
you cannot play
well doesn't look like you should play
queen takes e1 uh dropping the knight
and dropping a whole bunch of puns near
your king
that would probably not be ideal and i'm
still looking at this h5 move just to
give my king some space off the back
rank
he does take on e1 first that looks good
and brookdale how could you blame him
for
developing his pieces and his attack he
does luce said the a4 pawn so there i
wouldn't take that right now that's
going away from the king that looks
scary with queen g5 coming things like
that
but that pawn a4 at some point can be
captured so levy
how does periphery he's going to be
looking at that
definitely and the reason you want to
loosen up this wow he took it
excuse me is this a match of taking
random a pawns it looks like it robert
queen takes a4 and i mean this just
looks too greedy to me but hey
uh queen g5 that's the first thing that
comes to mind it hits the c1 rook and it
hits the g4 pawn with chat
look bishop d6 also is tricky because if
you play queen takes c6 then that rook
takes e1 shack distracting your rook
from the queen's
protection and when the queen recaptures
you cover the back rank so that tactic
would uh be good so yeah that wouldn't
work out for white there's this
trick and the rook's overloaded yeah and
the queen watching e8 is actually so
important in that line
so you really have to notice that to go
for it but it does work out perfectly
for block yeah i think bishop
d6 is the way to go because you're
staring right at that white king side
and it looks like you can mount a
serious attack so i don't even know what
the best response is to bishop d6
because your move queen g5 comes next
and he plays bishop b6
step one complete queen g5 step two
checkmate
inevitably step three that's a scary
three-step process
just that outline for our viewers here
robert um bishop d6
i mean you've pointed everything out
it's it's queen e5 it's queen g5
it's the fact that h5 gets rid of back
rank for black
and continues the attack um this looks
really difficult to meet because
that knight all you want to do is put it
on f3 and play king g2 all at once
but you can't do either of those moves
at the moment and you'll never do both
of them together
no you will not and just coming up with
a move is difficult for white if you
play queen back to d1
yeah you keep your king side safer for
now but i still make a move like h5 or
rookie 6 rook lift and
queen g5 is possible right now because
you want queen to c4 so i'm going to
play queen g5 and just
attack the g4 pawn keep an eye on your
rook on c1 what do you do here
do you like play h3 but then c5
how's queen takes c6 i mean are we
getting completely mated here like i
know queen takes g4 is like completely
ridiculous but
at the same time white just had to make
a move and with 18.7 seconds i think
queen c6 is reasonable
yeah it is and after king h1
you can just play d8 maybe and keep the
attack alive because that bishop on d6
is staring at the king and there's no
queen takes d6 which is important
there would be background checkmates but
the queen on g4 covers that c8 square
so you are safe for the moment and
there's gonna have to be an investment
by black
after defending the rook and taking care
of these pieces which are forked by the
way
uh there just is gonna have to be an h5
or a g6 move uh because back rank
threats
throughout this entire end game it's
just not possible to deal with
everything
and queen h3 is a pretty big threat
hitting h2 throwing the f1 square
that's why he drops the queen back to f3
and just bring your queen back
somewhere i'm not sure where yeah not
gonna be a trade here
no sir queen g5 maybe just uh hey maybe
you don't notice your rook's hanging you
have 4.9 seconds
yeah yeah
h6 for black just like give my king some
safety
maybe even uh at some point h5 because
it controls g4 but
yeah we just need upon we need something
in front of the king i would say
queen g5 okay there's that threat to the
rook
five he barely got the move off oh my
gosh queen it should check this king f1
what a
way to weasel out of this for levy yes
because he's playing on the light
squares now every piece is safe king f1
you can quickly
oh he walked right into it and he had no
time
and he shakes his head gets up and
bounces and eric's like
all right it's it's chill we're still
just playing
eric's just pouring another cup of tea i
mean it's just a day in the office
this is such an intense match eric rosen
takes
the lead at the end of the five minute
portion
oh what was needed there was just like
king f1 or something it just those those
two seconds you're never going to play
perfect chess
all the time amman seven games played
seven wins for the player with the black
pieces what in the world is going on
i think everybody in this match needs to
go and check their repertoire
and make sure they actually had some
openings prepared as white
because it looks like everybody's just
winging it right now and everyone
prepared with the black pieces or
something because
let's be let's be clear these guys are
playing great but
uh we're not seeing any big advantages
and especially not any conversions
with the white pieces no the the biggest
lead's been one it's been a win for one
player win for the other it's a strike
back immediately
so this is as even of a match as it gets
eric gets to go into the break with the
lead and before we take our break i just
want to ask your iman
and what's the mindset like for them
because it is really a 50 50 shot except
for
a you know win there in the final
position on time and getting checkmated
well i i think what we've seen from this
match is that uh these guys are allergic
to
uh draws let's put it that way um if
there's a time scramble and it's even
time
we don't see players offering draws we
see absolute chaos on the board
you and i losing our minds our voices uh
it
it's basically indicating that every
game seems to finish with a decisive
result
so time scramble skills are super super
important in this match and
coming back into it you just want to
regroup and remember in the three minute
portion
if you're getting in that time pressure
it's going to be even worse so that's
something to think about
yeah it's a good thing to leave our
viewers with we'll bid you adieu just
for now we'll be back in a few
and when we return we'll have more of
this levy versus eric speeches
championship match brought to you by
chess.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and just a reminder of our 16
participants in the upcoming pogchamps 3
it's going to be a great tournament
filled with your favorite streamers
celebrities poker stars and more amman i
know i'm looking for it starts
just in a few days from now yeah and
it's going to be an exciting one robert
if you've
you know been tuned into the chess
category you've probably noticed quite a
number of these players
um getting some coaching and getting
tuned up for the event which is exactly
what we like to see
the players are taking that as seriously
as the players are taking today's match
by the looks of it robert so
if uh today's match was a taste of
adrenaline in chess that you haven't
experienced before
uh we got that event coming right up we
certainly do and i am just pumped to see
how this match keeps going here because
seven games seven wins for the black
pieces both sides have had their chances
time scrambles have been a thing
and it feels like for levy better clock
management is a necessity at this point
in three-minute chess
you can't afford to spend two minutes
early like he did in some of the
five-minute games but then again he was
playing really good chess so it's hard
to fault him completely there
i don't know what the right solution is
yeah it's so hard to say i always say
live and die by the sword
but uh we're into this next match i
think at the very least
levy is gonna see three minutes on the
clock
and realize that that's a more
comfortable more natural time control
that's the arena kings format the title
tuesday
when he's playing blitz on stream that's
probably going to be more familiar
territory for him
and i think that that could you know
make him feel more comfortable yeah and
for eric
in some of these time scrambles levy has
gotten the upper hand so he needs to be
careful about that and as you said title
tuesday
has this time control and levy's beaten
even peter spidler
one of the very best players in the
world so we know that he has what it
takes to win games in this format and
right now we have another caracon
that b5 has just been played that is an
aggressive move that can often backfire
if
white can time an a4 push at some moment
so
that's a dangerous move to play if
you're levy especially having
not canceled yet and it looks like a
strange move to play
against someone who's got a knight on c2
because it controls the b4 square
so nicely and it it's full queen side
development over here bishop to b7
uh is he playing a castle queen side it
looks insane with moves like a4
so i'm questioning that bishop on b7 is
it ever going to get open
i'm looking at moves like queen e2
bishop g5 and just planting knight
in on e5 yeah that's thematic here and
if
your king finds it doesn't just drop a
pawn
um so knight takes e5 and then pawn
takes bishop takes e5
does he did he hallucinate some sort of
queen e2 bishop pig's
e5 thing like there's no there's no way
this is just a free pun
yeah that caught me off guard because
you were saying queen e2 and then 95
right
exactly and then he went 95 and i'm like
that doesn't look right because he
played that too fast and levy's sitting
here and calculating
is there something that we're missing
down the line here i'm trying to look at
the player cams for a reaction um
and basically rosen is probably like
oh my god if i move my eyes a single bit
he's gonna notice the pawn hanging
yeah he's doing secret service we have a
problem on the e5
square nobody move a muscle and yeah
levy takes it
and he is now up a pawn down 30 seconds
but upon him
i think that's a good response by eric
if you are going to blunder upon the
center
at least complicate matters playing a4
now if you take on a4 the rook can
capture it over there and the a6 pawn
becomes a target so the extra pawn
hasn't quite made its presence felt and
well actually levy gives the pawn right
back yeah you know i tend to agree with
you robert the
extra pun hasn't made his presence felt
because it's no longer there
and after a takes b5 technically you can
win that pawn back i still think black
has the edge and of course that was
definitely not a good sequence by eric
to give it up in the first place but
i guess you gotta take it back even the
stakes and say you know whatever the
position is that i have now
i just have to deal with it because
getting that pawn back is is worth more
than anything
very interesting to not take on a4 and
allow white to take on b5 giving the
pawn back
but as you were just saying black's
position is better look at this activity
the knight on e4
the bishop e5 and don't sleep on that
bishop on a8 because
if that diagonal opens up there could be
big trouble by the way bishop h2 check
forces the king to f1 if you go to h1
you get not just forked
but checkmated so levy first plays pawn
to f5 solidifies the defense that knight
on e4 he would like to take with the f
pawn open up that rook
and eric will not be capturing that's
for sure no and i'll just show
the people that check me because it is
it is pretty uh pretty funny the idea
just getting made it's so satisfying
to do with the knight basically a
smothered mate um so keep in mind
it looks like it you know maybe just a
silly tactic you know robert's just
having his
fantasies about smothered mates but no
it's really important to
uh focus on those tactics see them even
when they aren't forcing and they don't
work
because later on in this game we might
see that type of idea play into the game
that for sure could be the case and
queen b6 puts pressure on d4
says bishop e3 don't think so queen
takes b2 so levy has really liked these
queen b6 maneuvers throughout the day
and it also protects the e6 pawn so that
queen's doing it all
absolutely the only piece left to maybe
improve if you're looking at black's
position just a few small moves that he
wants to play
maybe bishop b7 just to get off the back
rank so that the rook can always use the
a file if necessary
also one step closer to bishop ca if you
need just more scope
and maybe just a move like h6 there's
always time for small moves like that so
i'm i'm liking levy's position as uh wow
bishop takes e4 that is quite a
committal decision
yeah that is a huge decision and the one
good thing for eric
there are not many in this position is
that the pawn on b2 even if your bishop
moves the e6 pawn is also an attack but
i like the way levi recaptured
because that bishop is going to go to d5
and so even though
you didn't capture on the f-pawn to open
up the rook your bishop is more flexible
and free
so levi's got a nice advantage here yeah
absolutely bishop e3
is the move you want to play so
desperately with the with the white
pieces queen takes c3
knight takes e6 i don't know what the uh
queen is b2 rather
knight takes e6 i don't know what the
evaluation is after that looks like he
wants to defend it and then go for
bishop e3
and the biggest difference between
taking the d and the f pawn is black and
also f4 if that bishop goes to e3 and
then maybe
e3 or f3 are both ripping open that king
side
and so i think that levy's in a great
position to even play f4 himself say
hey is that really a bishop on c1 what
you doing over there you can't get out
and i am going to try to push my pawns
and attack your king but look at the
time
45 seconds for black 35 seconds for
white we're getting into a bit of a
scramble territory
and that's when mistakes happen but
black really has a nice position at this
point
yeah and i was gonna say he's either
thinking about rook takes e4 or he's
thinking about something crazy and i
think it was crazy
knight f3 saying look if you take me
rook takes e5 what's even happening
there after f takes g2
yeah have that pawn i'll use it as a
shield that's an umbrella and
that way your bishop on eight looks
great but you're not figuring a way to
attack so he doesn't take
now knight g5 is possible rookie for
also possible i was just trying to save
the material
and he goes for your line because the
light squares are now under white's
control and the f4
i'm a bad influence i don't know if that
was the best but it's just such a
bullet instinct he saw those 20 seconds
ticking down now his position
hey it might not be the best but it's
very playable he's got two connected
outside pass pawns
and he has control over some light
squares be careful of that epon
getting to e5 and getting to e4 before
he can establish
the blockade he does have knight g5 now
but you have to think is there f3 coming
open up that bishop e4 check things get
really crazy at this point
so knight g5 there probably is that f3
move so he goes knight to d2
and now after f3 maybe he can go queen
e4 and say wait a second if the queen's
trade
well he takes it that can't be good that
completely shocked me i thought i was
gonna play queen e4 and try to trade
queens
and if the queens came off my point was
that hey those past pawns in the queen
side
could be worth the exchange down maybe
queen g5 and then take f3 you can't play
knight takes oh
that's that's for oh he takes and does
the bishop hanging yep
that'll be game all right so it's an
extra rook for just two pawns
and you need to prove it you're 12
seconds you're up on time you can do
this i would make space for my king at
some point
i would play h6 and just you know deal
with everything else later
um eric is going to play this because
hey he's got two pawns over there but
that queen trade i think is going to
cement things
yeah that's not going to help your cause
here rookie 8 the knights know we're
good to go
the c3 pawns hang ruxia obviously is
also good and
it looks like levy for the eighth time
in this match
with the black pieces the player is
going to win so
i guess we're just coming to expect that
black is going to win every single game
in this match
and i know there's there's not much
commentary to give at the end but i just
want to say
playing rook a8 there with the rook just
a really good habit to get into
you toss your rook super far away from
your king so that it won't get forked
yeah that's a good call and there's a
fork here but rook c4 you guys would
protect the bishop
that's good news and eric is the type
player to play out by the way three
seconds for each player
so there could be a flag and now rook c3
knight g4 if you take on f3 king g2 and
you
oh you can't get through
oh my gosh i knew it that's so
funny eric finds all of these stalemates
he did it last year against elizabeth
pitts and
he managed to actually get a stalemate
in one game but levy's too
aware of what's going on he's got some
free moves now and he's like all right
enough of this enough just take the
knife
wait oh it's not stalemate
[Laughter]
see that's what that's what rosa does to
you he sits there in his yellow hoodie
and he makes you think that every
position
on the board is stalemate oh my gosh
amman the way this match is going
wouldn't be surprised if we get to tie
breakers
and if we get to armageddon i know which
color the players are going to choose
it is certainly going to be the black
pieces
would be insane if black won every game
in the match and then won the tiebreaker
and
you know the players just went home and
that was the result
i wonder if this is getting to their
heads because obviously we're making
jokes about it but do you think they're
looking at their opening repertoire and
even in this game
levy sacrificed the pawn and if eric can
counter the initial pressure he should
have a good position because he's a pawn
up so
another game another kind of weird
opening choice
and if he can deal with the immediate
danger black will once again have the
advantage
robert i i mean i have to just go back
and show that stalemate
what could have happened because that's
so classic rook g3 king h1
and honestly i might have pre-moved this
in a game
yes like it's so easy to do you're like
okay rook g3 i finally won his knight
that tricky guy's been forking me
everywhere rook takes g4
and you know it's actually really really
good of levy to notice that
absolutely and good awareness by both
and for levy not pre-moving knowing when
and when not supreme was a very
important skill set
in these speed chess championship
matches and right now levy played the
crazy opening he's the one who
sacrificed a pawn then he spent
what 40 seconds on that decision here so
being upon down and spending the clock
that feels like it's not a good sign
for levy right now just castle king said
of him eric you mean the white king's in
the center
white king's in the center it's a couple
moves away from uh castling and knight
back to c3
it's still a few moves away from
castling what is usually called for
robert when stuff like this happens
maybe move like b5 b4
just something very ultra aggressive
attack that knight dislodge it again
go after that pawn i love b5 b4 because
it almost prepares if a guy goes knight
f3
you have bishop b5 after b4 you're
looking to cut that king and stop it
from castling
that looks like a phenomenal sequence
eric does play b5
and he is up half a minute on the clock
this is
at this point standard time controls and
knight f3 we're gonna see b4
and after 92 we will see very likely
bishop b5 and the d5 pawn is weak
this is looking really nice for black
once again
knight f4 maybe can be played there
might be a knight d5 in that position
i'm not too sure
i'm looking at knight g5 knight takes f4
and knight g2 but the problem with
knight d5 is you can just take back on
d5 because your bishop
that yeah i'm sorry to ruin your fun
that was a nice checkmating sequence
but i don't think it's gonna happen yeah
well
that i will take that off the table for
now but i still think with that bishop
on b5
there's no king side castling it might
even be queen d2
and queen side castling just forced
because you gotta get your king out of
the center somehow
yeah and even there it doesn't look very
safe for the king and black's king on
the other hand looks
very very safe and so what's the move
right now
he plays bishop c4 just going for the
pawn on d5
and that if b3 can he take on d5 i guess
he can
takes on d5 bishop takes f6 and then
even just
bishop takes back on f6 hitting the rook
on a1
which would be the case after b3 i think
he might have just missed that bishop
takes d5 bishop f6 you look like you're
undermining
the bishop on d5 but bishop takes back
is so strong
and eric's thinking here trying to
figure out if it works out for him it
does
but that may mean that he must put his
bishop back and say now you're not
casting kingside still
right and castling queenside is even
more dangerous because of your
pawn structure and all those weak dark
squares very reasonable to play bishop
b5 but
i think at the end of the day when you
see a pawn in the center of the board
and you calculate that you can take it
you almost gotta do it
yeah so he takes it and it's about even
on the clock an extra five plus seconds
now for eric
and the problem for levy is not the time
it's the position he is down upon i
would just castle
and i'm down upon i know it but at least
i'm moving quickly i have some clearer
plans
queenie two rook d1 rookie one just make
moves that
are natural here and black's extra pawn
is upon e7
not exactly in the game just yet yeah
there's i mean
you know down upon in a blitz game is
not going to be the worst thing
uh we've seen uh him almost get a
stalemate down an entire rook in a pawn
so
hey we'll we'll take down a pawn here if
you're levy uh
maybe queen e2 i feel like avoiding a
queen trade
is what you want to do queen e2 followed
by rookie 1 and rook d1 as you said
uh bishop b5 once again it rears its
nasty head here
trying to skewer the queen on e2 and the
rook on f1 and
weirdly white's pieces are just in this
strange order like the knight should be
on e5 but the bishop's there
and you know the queen's on e2 and that
looks fine but bishop b5 is coming i
think this should be five anyway
right now there's no good square for
that queen you go to the d-file
well hello there's rook d8 you go to e3
there might be knight g4
yeah that looks good he starts with rook
to d8 and oh bishop b5 is a very real
threat
so c4 i would take that thing on passant
probably
but then the bishop can capture back and
maybe the queen will go to b2 later
and that's the kind of play you need if
you're levy when you're down in a pawn
i agree yeah that that looks good
especially because it it might be backed
up by a queen
to b2 like if bishop b5 queen b2 all of
a sudden you're putting a lot of
pressure on that bishop on g7 and
pinning the knight
let's not forget it looks a little risky
right now but keep an eye on that e7
pawn
it's loose and if you ever play e6 as
black that queen b2 move makes a lot
more sense
yeah and the bishop on c3 is not
defended so you always want to look if
the piece goes out the way is knight h5
a move here
if you take my bishop on g7 i take your
knight on f4 with tempo
that kind of tactical sequence could
have been nice for
eric right there but queen b7 is such a
natural move lining your queen and
bishop
on the diagonal we're looking to play
bishop takes f3 and knight
g5 played so hang on a sec after h6
which is like the natural move
is there some sort of knight e6 or
knight takes f7 what's going on
that probably was the plan and that's
why eric would rook to d7s and all right
if you go 96 i'll have to figure it out
now
he does it but now these 96 knight takes
g6 all these tactics are flying
i guess eric's just going to take the
piece and they have to fly right now
though otherwise they won't work at all
that night he's got to make a decision
and i think with time taking down you
sort of err on the side of caution like
i don't want to throw this game away
with a
ridiculous sack unfortunately the
caution often is bad for the side that
sound material because it makes it
black's life easier here and
now you're up a pawn e5 is coming he
plays it the g2 pawn is hanging if the
knight moves out the way
oh no where can i not even go to knight
d3
but then bishop b5 is possible there too
so this looks like it's dropping
material
there's no way this works um g2 still
falls
plus you're in a completely nasty pin
and knight g4 right
to d7 is going to win the game okay so
where's the material he takes there
is there queen f3 nice move bishop
bishop f6
queen g4 check and take on h4 if the
rook goes to g3 steal some material he
goes queen of five hitting
out of the pin credit to rosen and levy
for
the the sequences okay queen g4 check
and the e5 is hanging so he takes just
right away okay you didn't even need to
move the queen and what's the finish
here what's that's a tricky move
queen f4 okay let's look at some time
yeah two seconds a piece
i'm trying to figure it out quick before
check one second and barely get the
giveaway
and now black is up oh rookie five at
some point is dangerous
okay for a levy he's he's moving the
queen but there's just no good moves
rook g5's
winning winning the game yeah that queen
is now hanging and that's one of those
situations move the piece out of the way
and then you get discovery
black wins for the night time in a row
it is about to be
an adoption with the black pieces this i
i swear to god robert everything i know
about chess
has told me that white is supposed to
have an advantage like there's a reason
that when you have a chess match like
the world championship you have an
even number of games so that one player
doesn't get the extra
well now i know the extra black pieces
would be having an advantage
right so it's not you know i'm not
wanting that extra white piece i don't
want to move first
i want to respond because then i have a
psychological edge and we get back to
this keracon and look queenie two this
time oman
he understood that 95 was two c he needs
the rook as well he
can't forget the rook this time there we
go there it is there it is all the
pieces lined up in the e5 square
and i like these positions for white
because it's kind of like a london
system in a way that bishop on d3s
hits across the position to the h7 pawn
so if you castle king side
95 happens bishop g5 your king could
quickly come under fire
because most of black's pieces are over
there on the queen side the problem
right with casting queenside though
is that a4 your pawn is too advanced on
b5 there so knight to d7
and weird move to play i was actually
wondering what you thought of maybe the
move knight e4
and uh giving up a pawn and playing 95
and just
kind of opening up those bishops and
saying hey that's a that's a way to play
you know look for a castle and a very
aggressive setup knight d7
much more passive it is much more
passive and you're also moving another
piece away from your king side so if you
castle that way
you're probably walking into a checkmate
attack and look at this knight g5
threatening the h7 pawn sacrifice on e6
or f7 so knight f8 played
but can't white just play a move like
knight e3 threatening the d5 pawn
bringing the knight to f5 perhaps
pins galore problems with that black
king in the center i think that this
could be a pretty swift game but
it's the white pieces so no this game
yeah of course not what are we talking
about blacks
looks much better here ignore that
evaluation bar
um i was going to say even taking on b4
moving that dark square bishop and just
getting rook c1 it's like the knight on
f8 sure
it covers things but you can't castle
now and queen h5 makes
yet another threat knight takes e6 is in
the position robert utilizing that new
pin
wow and where does black even go here g6
the queen just goes right up to h6
doesn't mind
hanging out on the g7 square because
that rook will get trapped in the corner
so this looks
really unpleasant for levy right now i
don't see a way to do it make queen d7
just like
protect e6 right now and say all right
there's no knockout blow
i can hold on maybe i will get to castle
eventually just i don't know when
eventually happens
yeah and it will be that g6 move queen
h6 to g7
is the threat and so rook g8 just to
stop it but
without even being up a pawn here just
look at the evaluation
bar it's you know cresting the two plus
two plus three almost
and i mean it's because you just look at
the position and it's clear to see
black's pieces are doing nothing they're
reacting to white's threats and there's
so many good things for white to do here
and castling queenside doesn't actually
shield your king you're walking into
another attack it's a different attack
but it's still a very strong attack and
actually
white can consider taking on h7 right
now just grabbing that pawn
and then the black king would have to
castle queen side after a trait of
knight so instead
eric plays the calm move surprising that
eric rosen plays a calm move
bishop to d2 just hitting the b4 pawn a
third time
yeah and really looking to say look uh
long castle c4
right i'm going to open everything up
there is no side of the board that's
safe for you the king side
not safe the middle well doesn't look
very safe and now that he's played this
we might see a very very quick
rook c1 c4 and just busting the entire
position wide open
and that kind of restraint shows that
he's a very strong player because
you could have taken on h7 but the
material is less important to him
than just dominating the board and not
giving levy any chances whatsoever
sometimes you take pieces give up more
squares your opponent look at this move
knight g4
coming into f6 your rook is going to get
trapped your knight on f8 is stuck the
f7 pawn is under attack so if you played
bishop e7
thank you for the f7 pawn don't mind if
i capture that i don't really
see moves for black that look the least
bit appealing and
f4 is there
and knight takes e6 there's like okay
maybe it's taking queens but there's 96
at the very least
yeah bishop f4 is one of those moves
that's like you know it might hold for
the second but i feel like i can even
take and play pawn g3 and just
kick your queen away and go knight f6
eventually and now you're in big trouble
yeah at this point i mean look at black
species they're
they're just doing nothing but let's not
forget levy is staying in the game i
mean i'm super impressed the way rosen
is handling this
you know very mature he's taking his
time he's not cashing in material
advantage but
the longer you wait to cash in an
advantage there's always a chance that
you
maybe miss a move and all of a sudden
it's not there for you to take anymore
yeah that check could pass its
expiration date and there could be a
time where black has like knight a5 and
closes down the queen side protects the
pawn of b3 stops c4
all at once and c4 now that you played
f6 looks even more powerful because that
e6 pawn
is now weaker because the pawn f7 no
longer defends his friend and there's c4
bishop takes c4 will hit e6 hit b3
the position is really opening up and
levy's king is the one that's not safe
the king on g1 is well that's
very happy to be there and maybe oh it
doesn't look good but maybe knight b4
um if you take it at least i take with
the bishop and make a threat on your
rook and then
maybe taking dc4 in the future is not so
bad that bishop on v7 opens up against
the knight on f3
that's a good call knight b4 is pretty
interesting he does play it here
and the bishop is hanging so you have to
react in some manner
you can't take on d5 you just drop the
bishop that wouldn't be good and by the
way that bullet territory
40 seconds for white 34 for black this
is where the mistakes really happen
and it's getting tactical if you look
bishop f1 is knight c2 happening with a
four
that looks kind of worrisome and he
takes their place rookie two
that seems to be a good call yeah but
why don't we maybe just
take the pawn on c4 and go king b8 uh it
doesn't look like the best but that
bishop
opening up in the knight on f3 you could
even take that and take on d4
yeah that's actually a good call and
then you just remove your bishop from b7
saying
i don't care about my king's defense let
me rip your king open but now that
bishop is a terrible french bishop
it's stuck behind a wall of pawns the e6
pawn is still weak 15 seconds counting
down for levi he doesn't even have a
good looking move
if you go 97 rookie one the e6 pawn is
weak what do you do here
bishop c8 maybe just to add support to
e6 bishop c6 dropping the a pawn yeah
that's an important one because you take
on a6 go right back to b5
and then you go for the attack yeah and
he he missed that
queen a7 maybe looking for a cheapo with
bishop d5 tape
that would be that'd be pretty funny and
here
once again one second oh my gosh he gets
the move off and where is the finishing
touch queen e3 looks good take that pawn
on b3
and that should be a second extra pawn
and the king's in trouble
yep and he takes that bishop a5 and he's
gonna grab the bishop because you take
the queen takes b8 remember the knight
on f8 the rooks are not connected
no that's a problem 1.3 seconds left so
bishop takes c6 he doesn't do it
and now all of a sudden levy's trying to
escape but his next bishop's trapped
oh my goodness look at it it's like he's
playing against horde chess
yeah oh tbc the queen drops the queen
drops
oh and that's a win for eric the first
victory for the white pieces of the
match
and now it is six to four our biggest
lead of the day
two point spread eric rosen who goes
into the break
probably pretty happy camper you
couldn't tell by looking in his face he
looks the same no matter what move is
being played he could blunder his queen
or make a seven move sacrifice for mate
and he still looks like he's just
not even playing chess yeah uh i mean i
think the
the wit the way the chat is going right
now the energy that you can feel from
the chat
i think you and i feel it as well robert
this is not only the most hyped match
but
it's also delivered you know there's a
lot of matches that are hyped up
this one is delivering it is so intense
it feels like it's just one
game swinging in the balance and it just
swung in eric rosen's favor
it's six to four he's opened up
currently the biggest lead
of the match it's been back and forth
every single game what do you think
these players are
going to be thinking about going into
the break robert as now eric has the
first two game lead
if i'm levy i need to keep this spread
at the maximum
because i believe levy is the favorite
come bullet time
but if you go down three games then you
think do i actually have enough time
eric is of course a good bullet player
so will i have enough time to come back
in the match so it's only a two point
spread
both players have had chances this was
definitely levy's worst game of the
match he had
no chance to get active so eric did
something
very accurately here to say levy you
just
can't move your pieces i'm going to
dominate the game and that's why we saw
our first victory with the white pieces
because levi just couldn't move so i
think that eric did everything right
that game
but this has been a very balanced match
thus far
yeah i think uh robert you and i are
going to catch our breath people in the
chat you know get those spam hands ready
and be back to cheer on your favorite
either levy rosman or eric rosen when we
come back
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and after our first win for a player
with the white pieces we see the match
score at six to four in eric rosen's
favor
mom we just had a brief break there what
do you think the players did do you
think they went to look at their
openings and work on their preparation
or just say
forget chess for a few minutes i need a
break well
i hope that levy took a look at that
line we've been seeing
because i think it's been the most
common line in the entire match so i'm
referring to
the knight a3 i think that's the easiest
way to remember it
knight a3 variation seems to be throwing
him off and i am not liking that setup i
mentioned it before
that i don't like this a6 b5 bishop b7
setup that he went for
he was bailed out one game because uh
eric basically forgot
and hung upon um so that game you know
worked out for him but
um i think that overall now that uh
eric's demonstrated that once he gets
that knight to e5 it's really really
painful
i think he needs to be real careful and
hopefully he switched that out
yeah and for a coach and content creator
known for many of his gambits and tricky
lines
eric has played a very measured match i
mean throughout this
one he's played his knight a3922 right
you're saying this 983 line
and he's playing for a positional bind
and he played a great game
in that 10th one and that's why he was
able to secure a two-game lead and for
levi he
is playing really well there was that
game where he ended up checkmating
eric with queen b1 checkmate which was
surprised but before
all the wild stuff happened he was out
playing eric for sure so there's been
very good moments for levi that he
shouldn't forget about even though
now he's down by two points yeah and
neither player
uh i think it's obvious to them but i
want to remind
everybody that neither player i'm sure
feels like this match is over a two
point lead not even close levy has made
up so many
differences in the bullet portion that
um you know we're not even done to three
minute here robert
and there's still bullet coming up so i
feel like there's still so much of this
match to happen and remember in bullet
things can move so quickly that you can
make up
way more points in that section alone
than sometimes the other two combined
that's can be the case and we've seen
that before and we have liftoff
in game 11 c4 played an e5 so we have
a sicilian with colors reversed and now
we have this f5 line
are we going to get this knight f6 d5
pawn sacrifice like we saw earlier
and here i think so because um well
levy's going to repeat it because it
worked out for him but the thing is and
here we go
eric i was going to say eric is going to
remember what the line actually is i
don't think he played it properly he
played knight takes d5 last time
a little bit too hasty i believe the c6
is the move right because if pawn takes
c6 you can even just take back with your
pawn and the d3 pawn is weak
and look at this eric playing instantly
levy took a pause
that's not good news for levy because
when you're met
with a pawn sacrifice and then e4 trying
to take over the d3 square with that
check keeping the king in the center
that's some scary stuff it certainly is
you can tell
for those wondering uh you know the
answer to robert's question hey what did
the players do in the break
this is what eric rosen did in the break
it looks really good because you're
planting the knight on d3 you could take
that pawn back on d5 with your pawn
and once you do that pawn on e4 is
protected which means the d3 square is
protected as well so
oh gosh what do you mean dude 95 i guess
a necessity and that's a good move
and queen takes d5 offering the queen
trade that 995 could get caught in the
center
yeah it looks like you pretty much have
to take this remember there's still
knight c2
as a follow-up afterwards to uh fork the
king and the rook
castling looks like a move but hang on
that night we talked about it maybe
getting stranded out there
is that something to worry about or do
you leave it out there and go for a
counter attack like bishop d2 or a3 on
black's knight
you need to because bishop d6 does trap
the knight that knight
is trapped in e5 you go to g4 i play h5
and there's nowhere else to go so
or you play f4 but you don't play that
happily you can even just
take on e5 play bishop e6 and then say
you have the two bishops quote-unquote
advantage
how's your bishop on g2 looking right
yeah at that point
white would need to reroute that bishop
to d4 a slow journey
um and the pawn on e5 would be a pass
pawn but also not connected to any other
pawn on the board
a potential weakness after something as
simple as knight d3 or knight c6
yeah you play knight d3 you play rook c8
you take over the queen side over there
and this is a big moment because taking
on e5 giving up the bishop pair
not easy to do and he does just that uh
no he is not yet so okay sorry
i thought he oh he does i was like
in the future well no i i actually
clicked on something and all of a sudden
the moves happen and i was like wait how
did that happen i didn't see the players
moving yet here we are
and predicting the future but eric just
playing good moves knight to d3
going after the b2 pawn taking the c1
square rook c8 next
we will see bishop c3 a very very normal
move here
uh the bishop is anchored supported by
the b-pawn and of course it watches over
the two pawns
that the knight on d3 was attacking so
bishop c3 i can see this working out for
for levy here i do think that eric has
the better position but there's
something about that bishop on c3 and d4
just so solid defending everything in
the position
if the the f-file can be used by uh
levy's rooks
then all of a sudden things could crash
down for for rosen sometimes you see a
a sacrifice like an exchange stack
opening things up let's say the rook for
that light square bishop on e6
followed by bishop h3 sometimes that's
the way to play with white
and a big problem that's going to be
here is if you instead of sacrificing
exchange go bishop f1
black can just play bishop f5 like you
could take me on d3 we'll get opposite
called bishops
but that's a passed pawn on d3 that you
have to deal with so that's what eric is
relying on here bishop f1
bishop f5 keep that knight oh he moves
it back i don't like that decision
no i i visibly was disturbed by that
move
like that that knight c5 is not the
right one because after this is he going
back to d3 no he's allowing it to be
traded
yeah that's you're backing up and it
allows levy the time to
connect his rooks but whenever look on
c1 the knight on d3 was covering the c1
square
so playing bishop f5 was defending
tonight allowing opposite color bishops
but white's excuse me black's light
square bishop
would have been better and that pass
pawn was stronger for black it was more
advanced so
instead we have this position i think he
has to go back to d3 now i don't like
the look of knight a4 you play palm b3
and there goes your knight
and d6 does drop that a6 pawn we've
talked about stray apons
in this match that's another one and he
does go back to d3 now
we've already looked at ideas like you
know if these rooks trade and white goes
for it the
pawn on d3 the black rock's gonna get
activated and again i think there's some
sort of security
that these guys have in the back of
their mind that hey there's opposite
bishops in this position
you know it's not the worst yeah the
rooks get traded it's immediately a draw
so
that's the thing that eric can count on
he's down upon but it's double pawns
opposite-colored bishops
you can't push that e5 pawn to passer
that can't move so i think bishop f5
and rook c2 coming maybe black can play
for more though right if you get a quick
bishop f5 bishop e4 yourself or bishop
h3 here
it's the white king that's in some big
trouble yeah and i actually
like maybe something like bishop c3 for
rook d2 i feel like you need to
wrangle some control of your own second
rank and there would also be an e4
threat after that as well that's true
and i'm wondering if i can just play
bishop h3 and
give up my pawn on b7 and try to
checkmate the king right if i get a
quick rook g2 check
and your king has to go into the corner
there could be checkmate and it's eric's
material
and he is up 20 seconds so he can think
before he just gives away this pawn b7
with check
but bishop h3 is a serious move it is
because the idea that robert's pointing
out
um and i'll just even put it on the
board bishop h3
let's say rook takes b7 king e6 brook
takes
g7 or something rook d2 and king f1
would be met by rook takes g3
discovered attack hitting that rook and
if the king has to go to the corner
i mean here you're already wondering hey
after king h1 rook f2
is it just game over or something like
that i mean this is already something
to be concerned about for sure and
that's why we did not see that instead
after the king went to c7 very smartly
levy trades
the rooks and this game is a complete
draw there is no way to make progress
because your extra pawn is doubled and
even if you get e4 and trade the pawns
there
you can't push through to e6 black
controls that square so this seems to be
a very simple draw i would be
extremely surprised if somebody wins
this game that would
yeah how could that even happen yeah the
thing is
basically uh rosen doesn't even care
about e4
even though e4 technically lights up a
clean clean pawn
it really doesn't matter as long as you
have the pawns
somewhere where you can protect them uh
this should be a super easy draw for
these guys i'm actually surprised
they're playing it on
the one thing i'd be worried about if
i'm eric is if g4
and some bishop f8 but you don't have
time because that's why eric brought his
king
over to f7 to make sure those pawns are
safe and it's like you we can trade
on d5 that doesn't bother me my king
gets the f5 square and you're not
getting your pawn
oh whoa that's kind of point of getting
one time here two seconds point six
seconds left and then you pre-move king
g6
which is a good call i wouldn't even
think i'd be being sneaky if i'm levy
you know some kind of quick
quick movie a bishop sacrifice bishop e7
here so if king of seven's pre-moved you
win the g5 pawn
yeah he's got two seconds this is uh
getting a little crazy
and he's putting up on h3 which is
really smart king f7 and then pre-bishop
c8 bishop v6 just
just go back and forth yeah you can put
that king on d7
um and then you pre-move this bishop
anywhere you like really
and now now he's seemingly got it under
control but man that was
unnecessarily scary for a second there
yeah that was
way too close to zero seconds remaining
and he does
blockade the pawn and he can just go
bishop g4 bishop e6 just do not put your
bishop on a square
where it can be taken and b4 played and
they agreed to a draw
okay there's always that moment where
you know it's a draw
and you almost want to just repeat moves
because
taking the time to go over and click
draw you might even click resign i mean
who knows that the hands are shaking
with the nerves i have done that before
and that is one of the worst feelings in
the world you're like it is
it's a complete draw and then you resign
and your opponent's kind of like what is
wrong with that person
i misclicked okay yeah who is this and
wow
levy looks like a guy who has taken a
look at that variation robert pleased to
see it
and he's taking a page out of eric's
book because eric's been playing knight
day three all match levi's like well why
don't i put mine
in the rim who cares about chess
principles if eric one of the best
content creators like myself is doing it
and we're both instructive coaches hey
let's put those nights on the rim baby
exactly yeah we just have to hope
there's not too many people taking notes
so we might see
somewhere in the 500 to 1200 elo range a
lot of nights on the rim after this
match
yeah this is something where as a coach
i often say
do as i say not as i do because this is
not recommended for you to put your
knights on
scoring h6 but it does make sense you
can bring your knight to f5
in the near future your bishop on g7
still is on an open diagonal but open to
what look at this poncho b2
c3 d4 your bishop doesn't look all that
strong there so i
do like eric's position out of the
opening here and watch out queen d2 if
knight f5 there could be a g4
trapping that knight so be very careful
if you're levy with that knight on the
rim
and that's why h3 not only are you
taking away squares from
uh you know the bishop the knight on g4
but also supporting that g4 thrust
if the knight gets the f5 and somehow
you can you can
simply trap it as you mentioned so again
i'm feeling these openings are really
working out
for eric but f6 and knight f7
finally indicates a brand new plan of e5
and that will require a reaction from
eric
and it's a risky choice because look at
those light squares on the king side
right the king on g8 that diagonal from
a2 towards that king
there could be some problems there so
queen b3 comes to mind but then levi
will play e6 but he wants to play e5 and
that's why eric says i'm going to strike
immediately
and look at levees he did pawn and d5
you take me i take your bishop on b5
you take on c6 i take back and black
will get the bishop pair with a lot of
open space
i don't think eric really wants that to
happen so he takes on
c6 and might try to keep the position
more close
i'm not i feel like i'm not a fan of
this you know it's not so bad of course
there's knight
c3 to follow you can take a knight c3
that looks good as well i was also
considering maybe bishop a4
and if dc4 d5 and just play against that
e pawn in that position so
i think that rosen still has a lot of
attractive options but there is an idea
to just
sort of play against the d-pawn here for
white which if you can imagine an
exchange between those two pawns
that is going to be an isolated pawn
robber something that we touched on in
some earlier positions
although if you take on c4 push that
pawn to d5 and then you can play knight
d4 at some moment queen e2 the e7 pawn
isn't happy the e6 squares whites for
the taking
so i'm starting to like the initiative
that white has
and that pawn on c4 doesn't feel that
relevant just yet
without now it does because he's saying
i'll give you e7
my bishop blockades your past pawn if
you take it and my pawns can start
marching
i really like that decision by levy yeah
and this is going to be extremely
double-edged we've got two bishops
a pass pawn for white here you could
also call it an isolated pawn
depends on which side uh you're playing
with here and also
b5 cementing that c4 pawn and saying
look later on b4 is c3 and it's black
who's gonna have a pass bond as well
although something thematic that white
will try for is d6 followed by knight to
d5 you push your pass bond even though
it's isolated
and get in trouble as if you can get
your knight to d5 behind that pawn
that's really good news for you he plays
g4 first where's that knight going
has to go back over to h6 and maybe
there's even bishop c7
then pawn to d6 then knight to d5 and
knight to d4 all the white pieces
seem to be cooperating and he leads with
his rook but that does allow levy to try
to trade some pieces
it does and i'm not sure about the rook
because there is going to be like a
brook e8 maybe bishop
f8 idea to trade everything liquidate
and
that bishop is doing a lot more from f8
than
it is uh from g7 and i was just checking
if rook d7 was a tactic
but it doesn't look like if there's a
roof takes e1 check good thing to look
out for
what about bishop c7 speaking of rook
takes d7 where's your rook going
yeah wow you almost have to meet that uh
i think you lose an exchange
hang on a sec there's not a good way to
get out of this wait what
suddenly like your movie broke to see it
i just take your bishop because the
knight in f3 is protecting the rook on
e1 and if you
trade on e7 f8 yeah but bishop takes d8
protects the rook on e7 so
you get to win material there yeah no
that's crazy
at this point i think you have to just
do it i don't see a way out he's
probably a little
dumbfounded that that works like that
that wins material because then i don't
have three
defending the rook on e1 is actually so
important it's key
that the rook can even take d7 because
of that so yeah i think i think he goes
for that
i don't know what move was better than
bishop f8 there
and black certainly has chances in this
game because the bishop pair
will thrive the pawn can go to b4 those
pawns are rolling on the queen side
you can blockade that past pawn which is
isolated maybe attack it later
f5 followed by bishop g7 back comes to
mind to use that diagonal and i think
levy has chances but i don't like the
clock situation
eric is doing really well and now levy
down under 25 seconds
yeah and f5 very interesting move
actually it takes away the e4 square so
i i think i think i completely
understand that knight e4 was going to
be really annoying
right and niagara's knight d forcing you
take on g4 in comes my knight to c6 or
e6
and that's a problem probably to e6 with
tempo blocks the bishop the g4 pawn will
fall right next and i don't think you
could take that thing the d-pawn
captures and goes to e7
that looks like a big problem maybe rook
c8 to prepare b4 and c3 some sort of
counter play there
keep in mind the knight is also going to
look to jump in to like d6 as a blockade
or even e5 to f3
i love that move 94 the knight f6 check
is devastating so he plays bishop e7
i think you just take on g4 and he does
black down to eight seconds 95 maybe and
then the f3 check and the g4 pawn and
knight d3
good move there what do you do king g2
and then just give up the pawn but
that knight goes to d3 and there's
knight of four check ideas so watch out
from g2
they're still forks yep king g2 is very
easy to overlook knight d3 there
oh my gosh in 30 seconds so this is
where that extra time
plays its part and he plays rook to d1
to just avoid all the knight forks
that's a good move
it is okay so what now 92 don't buy kg2
that allows bishop v6 knight for check
you want to watch out for knight forks
and he plays g5 and now he's going
knight f6 check
yeah now yeah six looks very tempting it
has to be met by just king g7
yeah because kfa drops the h7 pawn don't
want to lose that and knight d5 is
coming
right there's still h6 ideas though
undermine that knight he goes back and
forth he's not going to take a draw
surely
oh b3 nice move bishop six g takes the
e7 e6 pawn runs and i said e7 but it's
not there yet
but look at that knight of four hitting
the rook and knights through check takes
g5 coming your way now you got knight h3
oh he takes the e6 pawn which also was
hanging but still a good move but knight
h3 would have been crushing their knight
takes g5 needed oh my goodness he barely
made a move wait rook takes e6 the rook
gets back you take on e6 you're
threading rook 67 with check so bring
the rook back to e2 now and you win the
game but
i think levy had it there for a split
second he did he had it there
there was definitely knight h3 knight
takes g5 and now
it's gonna be too little too late as you
know eric is just consolidating
bringing everything back and hey we've
seen bishop brook and knight all on the
board in multiple games and
it usually works out for the guy who has
the extra rook
that is typically the case and eric
rosen takes the biggest lead he extends
his lead
to seven and a half four nav a three
point lead
and what i said earlier on is that levy
probably has to keep this within two
points he doesn't
he has a chance of coming back even if
it's a three-point spread but you start
feeling like it's slipping away from you
so if levy can win this game which might
be our last
in this time patrol because we have just
over six minutes left he'll be down by
two he has a chance he's playing
this the frankenstein dracula variation
which i loved as a kid
yeah this is a fun opening and
especially after queen h5
um if you're not familiar what to do
with black it's so easy to just
lose the game immediately it really is
and this line isn't as sharp because the
queens have been traded their lines were
actually
white stays upon down and tries to go
for a checkmate
but this is saying all right we have a
neutral looking position
we have seven pawns four minor pieces
two rooks just no queens on the board
everything is safe and sound but knight
d5 white is hopping
first into the position and if you play
bishop d8 then white plays c3 takes away
the d4 square from your knight and
it's not really much of an advantage for
either player
but it's one of those positions you're
like all right we're on neutral
territory
let's see who can outplay the other yeah
and both sides are going to do the exact
same thing basically
d5 d4 the only difference in the
position is
pretty much those bishops on b3 and d8
getting castled is nice and easy for
both sides so again super super equal
game here
and uh well as you said get a chance to
see both guys
with a fresh position and whoever is
able to generate advantage can say they
definitely outplayed the other i love
and hate the move f6 because it takes
away the knight jump from e5 or g5 later
but you can't really play king f7 look
where that bishop on b3 is if that
diagonal opens up the king could get in
trouble just because queens are off the
board does not mean that kings are
always going to be safe
so if that king does land on f7 a timely
c4 could be big trouble for black
yeah and let's not forget that uh you
know levy is a little bit ahead of
development he's castled
you don't need to be castled in games
like this but he is castled which means
that
you pointed it out king on f7 it's not
always safe to have
you know just that bishop on b3 lined up
against you and he goes bishop e6
oh this this is uh there's an imbalance
here robert so we are going to see a
game
somebody bring out their zurich 1953
book because i analyzed
a lot of positions just like this as a
child the problem for white is you have
the bishop pair
but if we trade the light square bishops
that pawn on d4
actually restricts the mobility of your
dark square bishop i will plant a knight
on c6
bring my rooks to c and e files and
black is the one with the advantage
knights can dance around these isolated
pawns the bishop stares into it and that
is not a good thing
for the white side so i've seen many
strong players
lose positions like this with the bishop
against the knight
and after pawn takes c4 i mean
is there a world of rook takes e6 or
wow wait oh this is hd5 yeah we both
said the same time that is a blunder by
eric
and levy can just take that pawn so
there's there's d takes c4 after that
for black but
he could have played that move instead
of playing g5 this is just him
completely forgetting and overlooking
that the arrangement of pieces here for
black is very delicate
and shout out to nemo for the huge raid
welcome everybody sorry we missed it
when it happened
and welcome to a very intense matchup
between eric rosen and
levy rosman aka gotham chess and he did
just take on c4 theramon
rook takes e6 as possible then bishop
takes c4 check the f6 pawn looks like
it's falling as well
how many oh oh that's that's too timid
of a move there
yeah i liked rook takes e6 i was
thinking about it earlier
but now that the pawns on f6 and hanging
i think that's
automatic you take bishop c4 and bishop
takes f6 now knight d7 i feel like
there's sacrifices here all the time
rook takes e6 again
oh yes there it is king e6 rookie one
check the knight on f5 falls
and very importantly the knight on d7 is
now under attack so if that knight we're
on b8
this sequence would not work for white
but because the knight is developed it's
actually a bad thing king d6
bishop f4 check i'll save my bishop and
then take your knight if king f7
bishop takes f5 and then the knight on
d7 is lost
this should work out for levy and you
can see that uh eval bar
is uh nearly going for the end zone
there in black's position because
there's a piece being lost here and the
best that looks like can happen is maybe
two pieces for a rook
but there's also so many pawns that have
been taken on the way
big match question for you iman there
are two minutes left
in this time control if you're eric you
haven't lost
the game completely yet but do you want
one more game
in this three minute portion because you
think levy might be the favorite in
bullet or did you say
all right let's uh keep this one going
and if the time elapses we'll just head
to bullet and
if my lead's two points that's still a
lot i think it depends on
whether uh he's the type of player to
even be checking the clock at this point
you know
and i think if he is yeah he might want
to play this game out
and and say look let's have this be the
last game in this portion
um don't wanna have uh levy mounting a
comeback you know right at the buzzer
this is a crushing position if we can
just let the time run out here
and i think that it will based on you
know how long this might take to convert
then i think that's probably what rosen
wants take that two-game lead into the
break
i would resign so i disagree with you
for the first time in forever
and the reason why is because eric will
get the white pieces and something has
been a little bit shaky for levy in
these caro con so i don't want to give
him time to prepare something for bullet
because in that last game his knight
went to h6 that was starting to look a
bit odd
in previous games his knight a3 lines
look good for eric so i think with the
three-minute time patrol
he has his best chance to maintain a
larger advantage whereas he is going to
lose this game i don't really see
a way that black survives this yeah he's
he's going to lose this game for sure
i i don't think i could possibly resign
a game
and then take the white pieces and
consider that an advantage at least not
in this match
so i'm just i'm just too scared to do it
you're right i'm on my bad
i just failed you as a co-commentator
but the position is completely lost for
black knight
forward jack wins the rook knight of
seven there's another fork 94 it just
actually wins it and if he resigns
he will get another game i'm looking at
the clock and if he's paying attention
he can resign with 15 seconds or 10
seconds left and get one
there it is he resigned he wants one
more
yep and and he definitely looked at the
clock there or he was uh
cognizant the entire time and will he
regret this because levy could win this
game take it to one
point differential but as you pointed
out this has been tough for levy to
answer and he might have thought of that
in those dying seconds
hey we need to go back to this does levy
have an answer for this variation
and this is where if any player with the
white pieces had an advantage it's been
in this line
for eric and you don't want to just
allow things to come down to bullet if
you can get that extra victory
then you're feeling good but i don't
think eric's the type players take risks
at this moment he's not going to
sacrifice pieces if it is speculative so
i think he made the right decision and
it's still going to be a game just
because he's playing with the white
pieces of course in this match
does not mean that he's going to score a
point in fact it's been going the other
way for the most part i just feel like
levy's had a hard time at this
point coming up with a way to counter
this opening and
you say that but i want to give him
credit here because i think one of the
suggestions i was making the last time i
saw this was maybe a knight e4
uh the knight on c2 you have to think
about what does that knight
not do on c2 what's the difference it's
not just a great move and there's
nothing wrong with it it's a given it
take
yes you have uh you know the the d4
square e3 under control but
you're not on d2 like usual so knight
into e4
f5 supporting and you sort of get this
almost dutch stonewall position
maybe we see him just castle here and
say look take me in the center i've got
the strong knight that you can't get rid
of
it's kind of funny because after c4 my
thought was knight to c3 and then i just
remembered and listen to you the
knight's on c2
so the knight is not on b1 but he plays
93 he attacks the center
that pawn on d5 surprisingly difficult
to defend you can play queen f7
you can't play knight e7 or maybe you
can but i'm looking at c5 as a way to
get that bishop
on d6 almost trapped so it's a situation
here where you have to be very careful
if you're levy because when you play d5
and f5
there are weak dark squares that you
have to deal with so i think the
position
oh okay go for it so c5 bishop f4
is available right and so he's not going
to lose that piece of course
but it's still it still feels a little
bit shaky but i guess bishop f4 and keep
in mind that light square bishop
hey it looks terrible right now but the
maneuver bishop d7
bishop ee bishop h5 it will get there
eventually and that's actually super
annoying to deal with
and look at eric justifying his move c4
following up with queen to b3
there's a lot of pressure on this d5
pawn and it's actually hanging in the
current position
and there could be tactics where the e4
square is a problem
because there could be a pin on that
diagonal so
watch out for tactics here queen a5 play
the rook on e1
is defended for the moment i almost
thought wait a second is that rook under
attack no you can take on d5 if you want
but you have to find a follow-up you
just don't take on d5 and hope that it
works you need to
find something because black has some
tricks up history with knight to g5
and what a way to defend that pawn queen
a5 is not normally a
resource you lean on to defend your
center pawn especially with all the
pressure
building up here the queen lining up
towards the king on g8 queen a5
combining defense and attack eyeballing
the rook on e1 as we mentioned i think
that's a great move by levy to try to
hold the balance
and watch out for knight g5 right now
because that rook needs a defender
and knight g5 thunder just take on f3
and remove the rook's defense while
shattering the white kingside pawn
structure
so levy's thinking here he can take back
on d5 but i feel pretty confident he's
looking at knight g5 ideas
and that could spell big trouble and
there it is that's a big move
it is and you can react to this in a
number of different ways but what looks
unavoidable are the double pawns here
yeah that doesn't look very pleasant
either and well you can react a number
of ways or if you're eric rosen you just
don't react at all
we don't even know if he's playing in
the game right now
yeah that's true it always uh comes to
question
at some point eric's cam could freeze
for the entire broadcast
and he would just come back at the end
and i wouldn't notice the difference
for sure and we see him here you know
he's looking at the board trying to
figure things out
levy i think he likes his position based
on his posture and look at the clock
eric is the one down under a minute
while levy has over a minute and a half
this is turning and maybe i was wrong to
suggest to play another game
because levy it feels like he's hitting
his stride at the right moment
yeah and he i think having an answer oh
god
there should be four four four it just
wins on the spot and he takes it
first but bishop b4 is next that's over
that's over black black wins proper
oh no and it's the biggest reaction
we've seen from eric all day he gulped
and he was just like okay that's a
problem there goes that rook
and it went from a potential two-game
lead to a one-game lead so
getting that last game in levy must be
like oh you tested me
all right that knight e4 jump didn't see
that one coming yeah and
and just having something ready for that
was not expected by
rosen because he's thinking hey that
worked out the last time we played it
and i haven't gone back there since
let me do that again it's up to him to
show me that he looked at something and
unfortunately for him the preparation
you know it wasn't like he prepared
everything to win but he just had
the ideas prepared and he knew exactly
where he wanted to put his pieces
he executed the strategy that said you
got to finish things off here
you know the there's nothing to lose for
eric so he's going to be playing
uh until this one is absolutely over
that's right in hindsight they say it's
20 20. i still think that eric
made a good choice i mean he was looking
at his own he had a good looking
position
but you have to give full credit to levy
finding this move queen a5
just causing all sorts of problems the
d5 pawn was defended but that's not what
it was about
it was the tactics and eric walked right
into a trap
now levy brings his queen to h5 and the
pawn h3 is under attack
eric has 10 seconds he plays kng2 which
is a reasonable choice
i'm looking at that knight trying to get
to h4 but don't move the knight yet then
the e pawn starts rushing up so
still not the easiest conversion but
levy
should win this without too much
difficulty yeah there's one thing there
um you know maybe it was unnecessary but
bishop e6 was potentially playable
because the queen on h5 was watching the
bishop on a5
um and maybe sometimes you can just sack
bring the rook to the middle he decides
that well i think he forgot as well
as i was saying that and that's not
gonna that's not gonna cut it for eric
rosen here
no that's another piece down the drain
and levy has 40 seconds
so he is way too much time and eric is
the type of player we've said this many
times at this point
he plays on until the game is checkmated
he does
this all the time it's not a matter of
respect some people think oh it's
disrespectful to play
he does against everybody so it's just
what he does and he has every right to
continue this game and the time's up
for this time portion so he might as
well and i think when you demonstrate
time and time again that you're able to
trick even the strongest players into a
stalemate trap
at the end of a game it's like okay you
can you can play on
you know you you are clearly doing that
not
out of anything other than your own
creative uh you know canvas to play with
and he does it so many times so
um he almost did it in this match robert
and it's just
i mean queen takes e4 was a free rook
knight to check you can take that rook
next have fun with it
and now it's an extra rook two minor
pieces king is not safe
you have less time everything is going
on
for good measures for good measure there
goes the queen and levy
he has some bounce because he just got
up he
airlifted out of his chair and i mean we
might see him levitate if he is able to
continue this winning streak yeah i know
he he just bounced uh
took off to space if his uh sweatshirt
was any indication of where he was
playing from
uh knight c5 to finish off a confident
game from levy rosman and
we were worried about this happening you
know if you're looking from eric rosen's
perspective he takes that extra game
he fully made that decision robert and
now he's probably regretting it do you
think that
he's going to be thinking about a flurry
of emotions going into this break
hard to tell by looking at him but he
must be feeling
negatively about his chest in the last
few games because levy did outplay him
there
and so he's only up by one point he saw
the win in sight three game lead
everything's going well and now it's
down to one
levee is the high rated ball player
however eric himself is a
very strong bill player i believe his
reigns are 26.50 so he
should be right in this come bullets
oman
i think we're going to take our final
break and when we come back we will have
the bullet portion
levy just at one point you will not want
to miss the finale
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we couldn't ask for a more exciting
match it is seven and a half points for
eric rosen
six and a half points for levy rosman
levy down the scoreboard but on a
winning streak a mom we just took a
break so did the players
how do you think they're feeling right
now well
if you're rosen you're probably a little
dejected i mean it's hard not to be
you could have taken a two-point lead
into this bullet uh
segment completely your decision to get
another game doesn't mean it was the
wrong decision at the time
but obviously you look back on that you
reflect and you think man
you know what would it could have
shoulda and that's not the right
attitude so hopefully he's not thinking
about that too much but it's very easy
to think back
on that decision as you know this match
looks like robert it could come down to
a single
game in either direction and it could be
that game that he decided to get at the
end of the three-minute portion
and we know he loves to drink his tea
hopefully it's heavily caffeinated
because in bullet
you need to be alert at all times you
need to be ready for tactics galore
and it has been levy in the last couple
of games who's been striking
when the tactics are available so rosen
he's been a bit shaky in the last two
but we can't forget
the prior games where he jumped out to a
three-point lead so right now
just the bullet portion left 25 minutes
of it come on i'm super excited man
yeah this is honestly the not only is it
really close going into bullet we've
seen that before
but you get the feeling based on this
match it's a win for one side a win for
the other
a three-point lead from rosen cut back
down to one by
levy neither of these guys is going out
without a fight and i think this is uh
going to be an extremely exciting
portion so
you know everybody in the chat strap in
b3 on the board that is bullet opening
here we go did he call hit car during
the break because he goes b3 which is a
karu's pet line
and e4 upon sack if you play d takes e4
the f pawn can't capture the bishop pins
upon f3 but it's a pawn sacrifice and
eric spending some time to figure it out
no
oh look at this knight c3 knight takes
f3 if you take it just trying to get all
the piece out bishop c4 queen e2 castle
queen side
and eric saying you know what i'm just
gonna leave that pawn there for now and
keep an eye on this bishop there's a lot
of tricks in this opening like queen b5
check
picking off the bishop on h5 that's a
good call and knight d7 deals with that
and says
you can win this pawn back on e4 i'm
happy to give it back to you we kind of
have a scandinavian vibe a scandi
where the d-pawn is gone for black the e
pawn's gone for white and wait a sec
there was knight f6 with queen b5 ideas
right there
yeah wait a minute knight f6 there's
some bishop takes queen b5 stuff but
you have to be careful that rook on a1
was hanging so don't know if it was
completely winning
good call it's easy to forget because i
was focusing your attack but that rook
in the corner was under attack it looks
like eric
had things at least barely holding on
there and he was actually
that's a good move when you fianchetto
you can push that rook pawn to try to
challenge it a4 locks it up c6
you can't play b5 just yet your key
needs the castle first whose king is
safer because here comes h4
yeah this looks really good for levy
h4g4 and there's already going to be
tons of tactics
if you have to play h5 or h6 in this
position complete disaster robert
knight takes g6 which is why he played
bishop takes e4 you're thinking hey
giving up that bishop that doesn't make
sense it's because h5 was gonna put that
bishop in a coffin
very good call there by eric and if e5
he brings knight to d5 which is right
let me go knight d3
awkward situation with queen e2 bishop
f1 blunted by your own knight
and levi can just push all his pawns g4
threatening g5 the g7 pawns under attack
and g5 still that wins the pawn yeah
this this looks great i mean g7 is
hanging
why not take that there's bishop h3 to
follow up and hey use that f file next
rook f1
uh this looks fantastic for levy well
done and it looks so strange with the
knight md3 brings it back to e1 not
trading pieces
trying to go d4 challenge the 95 and
have to drop back to g6 but there's the
f4 square the h4 pawn there are tactics
available for black and he's evening up
on the clock he was down by quite a bit
now it's about uh even yeah and knight
d3 can follow up as well covering the f4
square
rook to f1 hitting f7 is gonna be lethal
i feel like
going forward h pawn also hanging yeah
levy's final game of three minute was
great this is probably his best game of
the entire match
yep there's going to be some counter
play with rook takes h4 and i was going
to say levy actually up on the clock
he's more used to the bullet portion but
now it's evened up and it's anyone's
game
yeah and then bishop comes to e4 taking
on g6 is the priority you could take
there
and the trade that works in f8 but then
that rook on h4 is kind of annoying the
pawn g5
is weak the bishop on b2 defending d4
but not very active in five seconds
you've got to move exactly rook g1 a bit
passive
error gets active and the works on h2
yeah what's going on b1 king b1
getting out of bishop g5 with check rook
takes g2 queen g2 and already the other
rook comes in i think
this is going to be anyone's game 12
seconds look at the time advantage for
eric rosen and the rooks under attack
you're gonna bring your rook back
probably h7 to cover the f7 square good
idea
rook f7 perhaps queen d i like that g5
is hanging you can just grab that pawn
but you lose g6 so he's trying to figure
it out
he goes queen eight covers that knight
f4 oh this is getting really really good
here for levy i feel like but bishop g5
is a great strength wait is the knight
trapped in g6 rook g7
yeah nice [ __ ] it's stuck in the corner
oh my gosh nobody puts the knight in the
corner except levi e4
oh bishop takes d4 was available there
then he doesn't want it
the knight's trapped okay it can come
out but rookie knight d2
oh 92 wins d4 that's really important
and there it goes knight 64 who's better
two seconds a piece
oh my gosh rook see you work up seven
you can win b7 you can win c2
there's no mate if both sides are trying
to mate the other knight b5 looks like a
good move take that knight
okay see two is hanging so now it's even
material in the rook ending but
someone's going to lose this game though
someone has to good move king ceasing
over c6 and he defends the e6 pawn
and now his pawns are safe his king b6
and king c5 can oh you're hanging b7
b7 is hanging open now the king's coming
to b4 rock d6 rookie's huge
is huge he plays it and kicks the fight
back he goes here oh now the b6 and e6
once he's six and e6 with check okay
take him a fourth it's sure white has
lots of time it should be a draw here
rook
to e8 the king should chase the bomb
wait for e7 and if rookie five would be
a check
a rook b7 though brilliant brilliant
defense
and one second oh we touched the book
the rook covers the square look at levy
he cannot believe it
oh my gosh it's a typical you're
wondering what the hell was he thinking
it's a typical idea when the pawn is one
square from promotion
you want to put that rook anywhere on
the board but anywhere except that
square because the rook takes it
and covers the queening square and we're
right back into this opening
robert the the emotional rollercoaster
is just beginning all aboard
oh yeah great first half of that game by
levy then great
resourceful defending by eric just to
stay in that game and against that
knight to the corner we have this
position that eric has loved the knight
a3 variation
of the car con levy queen c7 bishop v6
that's looking good but look at white
aiming on the e file 95 coming and you
don't have that many pieces defending
your king
over there on g8 yeah and i wonder i was
going to say is he going to go for
knight e7 some sort of knight g6 to try
to plug
the position maybe knight f5 as well uh
also using the b
file and maybe getting a knight to e4
the knight on c2 does not look as
effective from this position robert
knight e4 blunts that bishop on d3
that's really important to get that
knight e4 move we saw
levi used that with success in the end
of the three minute portion and now rook
to b1 keeping on that bishop on b7
and 94 still a possibility here what the
problem is for white is you wanna play
bishop g5 and be
active but black is just clogging the
lanes knight g6 is your bishop on d3
that's not that good of a piece
and if you take on g6 just h takes
closing down diagonals and white's
pieces suddenly don't have the same
mobility that they do in some other
positions
well you mentioned hey you can't do this
bishop move well he says i'm doing it
anyway
and knight d7 instead of knight e4 which
i was expecting
by levy would have been so consistent
with his play i think that 94 and just
bring the rooks to be it and see it is
all levy needed to do in that position
this bishop pair
not terribly convincing and i would
consider f takes here but f
even if you have to bishop e7 to d6
that's the idea that eric look at that
here comes that bishop e5 is suddenly
very protected
very safe and that bishop on b7 is under
attack so there's no queen takes c3
because then you drop that bishop down
there yeah that's important and
that that b8 square being covered by the
bishop on d6
very underrated there he's not going to
be able to challenge the
entire b file maybe for the rest of the
game and i wonder how he's going to even
develop his pieces here like bishop
c6 bishop c5 might have been necessary
good move though a5 bishop a6 just to
get that bishop out
the problem is the b file is under
white's control it's the only fully open
file in f6
such a dangerous move queen g3 the
immediate response e6 is weak g6 is weak
there could be an ef6 and even a sack on
e6 if you're not careful
and eric brings the rook up we're going
to come to f3 otherwise come to e1
that pawn on e6 is in trouble yeah levy
is in big
big trouble here everything's defended i
mean you can take a4
a straight a pawn like we've seen before
but you got to watch out your king is
getting trackmated time is taking you
down it's so hard to play defensive
moves under pressure
and look at this just dark square
dominance by white's piece of the e5
bishop f4 queen x4 queen
wow i'm a good move by levy and look at
three
oh they couldn't take on e3 that's so
hard to play 96 check wins the queen
though
1960 king d7 rookie 7. oh
wait that would have held on for a bit
yeah i mean there's a there's stuff here
there's a rook hanging on e3 it's not
completely over
that was wild and we get this line with
the early e4 push
by black saying my pawn if i was under
attack by this fiance bishop it's this
nimzo larsen position that's popularized
by hikaru nakamura
and typically black should go h5 h4 and
start attacking this nine g3
but you have to watch out for your
opponent e4 and this is actually a line
that i play
against this so i've had my fair share
of matches against hikaru
i mean i just can't for the life of me
beat him in this in this
line but uh it's a typical way to play
what you do is you have two bishops
a wide open central position whereas
white has this sort of
snake-like pawn mass that goes from a2
all the way over to f3
yeah fewer pawn islands are generally a
good thing and having that connected
pawns you can go d4
e4 push those pawns forward and that
bishop on b2
it may be blocked by the knight from now
if you've ever played g6 that bishop
reigns supreme on that diagonal seem to
be very careful yeah and
what we're seeing from eric rosen here
is just classic stuff rooks to the
middle of the board
open files this is very easy to play and
don't be surprised to see these bishops
even go all the way back to c8 or f8
because they can exert their pressure
from you know very very far away that's
exactly the strength of the bishop
yeah you might have to rely on that
because that bishop can be caught on h3
just
under attack it won't get trapped but
they could be hit with a attack like a
rook g3 or something and doubling the
rook so you have to be careful and the
bishop may find its way back to see it
as you're saying
yeah okay here comes bishop g6 is it
going to be d4
d4 you can always hammer away at that
structure with f5
and he's going for f4 well you know d4
now with tempo so he
bishop c5 said you didn't play d4 the
first time well now it's probably time
to do it with tempo
but that puts the pawns on riskier
squares white has
the commanding control the center with
the pawns but you can chip away with f5
or c5 or both
and that center could collapse yeah
absolutely the rooks are poised for that
and
this is just the type of thing in bullet
it's so hard to keep everything
guarded you're constantly looking is is
e4 protected enough is d4 protected
enough
you put too much pressure uh you know
defending one pawn he just attacks the
other so you have to be
uh always looking and here we go here's
c5 the first attempt to chip away at
that central mass
and c4 it's a thematic sacrifice but
maybe i can just take it because my nf2
is defending
oh but look at that bishop on b6 is that
even a bishop anymore does that qualify
as one
wow and he just went for connect four
five six in a row
that is looking good eric rosen here
he's got the bishop pair
he's gotta activate but he's got the
center here for levy so
very double-edged game oh bishop a7 to
go b5 to open that bishop up here it
comes
c4 the queen's in line with the rook the
rook wins that battle the bishop on a7
is alive
the next rook can come to c7 this is
look at c3 maybe
oh you're in check that's a good check
good check yeah that robert was really
on a roll there there's nothing going to
stop him not even a chat
no not even a check i don't care if it's
legal or not i'm doing it but bishop
came to b8 that bishop can come to e5
and then you can try to push that c pawn
yeah bishop e5 here
uh i mean that bishop on f7 it looks
like he's doing nothing but
timely f5 or even bishop back to f7 one
second wait one second
you gotta go i just noticed the time and
quit if i'm scaring the pawn a6 queen
because i had a great response
bishop d4 rook b1 oh my gosh it might be
a mate bish should be sent a good
defensive move queen a4 is queen b5 so
he goes back and bishop d6 probably
comes rook b6 go rookie six rookie one
rookie queen
oh my gosh queenie five oh rook takes
you second queen
wow completely completely crushing levy
is looking to make this a match
he can bring the queen in and he should
be able to execute the mate bring the
knight in that's the last piece that
isn't participating
and the key was that queen of four check
but none of us saw that king was in
check
none of us not a single one of us not
even you amman i know
but you don't even have to check no and
now it's over
eric lose on time but he was lost on the
board he was a queen for a rook and a
checkmate attack
levy down only two there are 13 and a
half plus minutes right now
going back to this carrot con if you
were levy do you continue playing this
cairo because i feel like
eric has found a comfort zone so i feel
like eric's found that comfort zone but
it's bullet and changing something up in
bullet can be disastrous if it doesn't
work out for you then you start to lose
confidence so
i think the value of him just being able
to make quick moves
is going to be fine it's bullet after
all and i think that
in general this knight e4 has been a
good counter to this opening
once he plays knight e4 i've usually
liked most of his positions
and look at this pawn structure doubled
f pawns newer players hate stacked pawns
but what they do a good job is look at
the e4 square that's blacks for the
taking
and the king isn't unsafe just because
the g pawn has moved and look at this
knight
rerouting over to g6 if i am eric i'm
trying to get open
on the queen side as black diverts
pieces to the king side
let me play rook to b1 let me play pawn
to b5 and use my bishop on h2
which slices across the diagonal taking
away the b8 square and that could be
good for white to open up that side oh
look at this why are we seeing knight a1
we saw knight h8 in a previous game well
it's going to go to b3 it's going to go
to c5 and it's going to be a great
outpost can never be kicked by the b-pod
because of the pawn on a5
and he goes king edge one just getting
out of the line with the rook knight e4
played you
need to keep that rook on f1 you do not
move that piece into c4 square
blacks for the taking the c4 square 16
you see five square whites for the
taking
i prefer the c5 score it actually puts
pressure on a pawn where c4 is staring
at air though it's a nice outpost
yeah and and we might see the move g4 at
some point it looks weird but it's
sometimes very thematic and
queen e7 it should be six anybody e6
yeah oh it doesn't play it
and now the knight can move out the way
because you can capture that knight and
take on b7
and that's an essential pawn to the
defense c4 knight c4 and knight b5 both
look reasonable c4 looks a little bit
closer to the action so to speak the
annoying thing about playing this
position the black side that knight and
c5 was never leaving
neville and so you look at the queens
that's clogged up here
and bishop h6 is i will give you oh and
he goes f4
he doesn't want that b7 pawn he just
wants to close this position down nobody
wants that b7 fun
poor guy valentine's day coming up yeah
well it's
it's going stag because gg3 knight goes
back to g6 and maybe now
maybe now no no it's i'm not gonna
capture it nobody wants it
it's just a guy looking for a date i
mean
oh gosh take it now come on do it a
favor
it it's still there surviving
to see another day and if you're not
careful for white this knight on d7 can
come to f6 and into e4
and do the same thing the knight on c5
is doing that's exact that's probably
going to happen whoa
d takes c5 is there some rook takes g3
nonsense no oh my gosh now it's just
dominance you if you trade queen oh
trade queens
this is really nice end game for white
and you're up two points
you have ten almost eleven minutes in
the clock you can waste a lot of time
even if you don't win this game but
black has
where are you going for h4 close it down
and there's nowhere to make progress and
at some point white can consider the
move c4
watch out for that move yeah he's
considering it right now rook do you
want anything oops
he had c4 now it's not as good but he
can still play it just to open up the
file but
g3 pawn's the problem yeah and and now
there's maybe a c4 again
he keeps missing it and then when he
sees it levy's like oh i see it as well
yes but he could still go c4 even if it
doesn't pin the pawn
so he's bringing his king around to play
c4 yep here it comes
oh my gosh that's really c7 rook takes
d5 but rook takes g3
nice call c4 there it is it's pinned
finally and uh levy levy's in
big trouble here takes and rook e5 or
although the g3 pawn hangs so yeah
is he going king c3 king d4 whoa i like
that move oh king d
king d5
who's better here black is better now
look at that king that's a hero and
where do you win rookie six let's bring
the rook back rook to e6
g to e6 and bring the the rooks down
this is
all of a sudden good for black you can
play d3 and a king d4
and then rookie two check look at that
king it's a hero went all the way from
like g7 to
d4 wow and look at this rookie two check
trading off some rooks king c3
bring that king in oh my goodness and
you can't move you can't take the rook d
e's
nothing to do and crooked two meet the
king helps in the checkmate
oh my goodness rookie three yeah this is
just completely winning eric gonna waste
some time
but it's about to be a one-point match
with nine minutes remaining plenty of
time
for levy to continue this comeback that
is insane because we all saw that
position and eric was so focused on
trying to make progress
that he kind of forgot that hey if i
over push i can actually
lose this game he's going for his
stalemate
but he's going to get checkmated instead
and as you mentioned robert
a one point game in levy would you agree
he's starting to find his stride a
little bit in this bullet portion
he is and eric had such a good position
it was vision in classical chess he
could never lose that
ever it was close he was the one with
the only pawn break with c4
and then somehow he lost the threat in
great move d4 by levy
and we have this nimzo larson attack b3
to start the
compact pawn structure for white the
bishop pair for black
and we see levy go back to this but look
at this the early bishop a3 says i can
trade the bishops so the king feels less
safe
without that fianchetto there and i
don't know if that's good or bad
because you know white's gonna go like
queen f2 d4 maybe rook to e1
and black doesn't have a bishop pair
anymore so now all those
things we were talking about the last
time we saw this don't necessarily apply
you can't just open the position and say
hey i'm better i got a bishop
two bishops you can definitely do that
although with the king on b2 knight city
queen e5 could be a big nuisance that
pin
is still alive and that's why he plays
team b1 that's a nice retreating move
the knight now is free to go
but how does white proceed from here if
you play f4 the g4 square
becomes vulnerable so f4 here h5 for
block give me that g4 square and he
plays knight e3 first queen e5 i'm
bringing that queen to center
taking away f4 from you i i like queen
f2
starting to get on the dark squares
maybe queen h4 f4 uh knight d5 is always
in the position black almost wants to
play
bishop c8 or bishop d7 and get over to
c6 or b7 but maybe he should have played
a5
himself yes this looks a bit scary but
the good news if you take on b6 you
undouble your pawn so that is good for
black
from a structural point of view but what
you need to do for white is somehow
trade a pair of knights
and then try to get on a dark square but
it seems very difficult at this point
maybe we can get d4
like somehow play d4 in this knight c4
uh there's
okay there's that move queen e5 f4 comes
to mind
f4 it doesn't rook a1 the open a file
that makes sense king goes to b7 knight
c4
watch out for that move that could that
big for white to hit the queen hit the
b6 pawn take over some of those dark
stories and look at b right g5
yeah that's rook g5 is probably good but
i like that move b5 just taking away
knight to c4 so queen d4 it looks
strange but threatens b4
so he has to go back and that's a good
queen trait that is a very very good
move knight to d1
now if b4 you take the queen and there's
no intermezzo because the queen can take
back on c3
okay so where to go to you want to use
the dark scores for both players right
you want to get this knight maybe to d7
to e5 but look at this that pawn go to
f4
maybe f5 crack open the king side and
that c2 to e4 pawn chain
feels very safe yeah it's so strong but
i think the pawn should have been kept
on f3
now maybe you can try to undermine it i
don't know how c4 is but maybe that's
too
too harsh too right i do like that move
a5 just pushing your pawns where you
have an extra pawn
and now rook g8 okay you defend but fg
and then rook to g1 that
you take on f5 you can't take on a five
the rook is protected
that actually might be swinging things
to black stuff and there's no rook takes
f5 no now you can just
i don't know what you can do now it's 94
though but knight e4 maybe there's
knight g4
like can i do something like that right
okay so 94 played i can even take
knight takes e4 he plays knight to g4 i
do like that move
take that in knight f6 though oh wow
because you do not want to take on g5
that's for sure
he plays f6 not sure about that move
yeah i'm not a big fan of three seconds
left for black i didn't even notice the
time
if you take on g5 the oh whoa
they're talking about the other thing
but oh wait takes on g6 wait oh they're
works hanging the rook sings you can't
take the knight
rookie six knight takes pawn takes and
then you have h5 oh roxy's h5 is winning
it's winning for what oh he blew it
he left the rook hanging and he doesn't
even react how do you blunder a rook
and just take more of a nibble out of
your sweatshirt and nothing else
who is this guy and levy is about to
even the score he you could sense he
breathed it out he's like this is even
but he's still nervous i have to imagine
that eric is nervous too
and it's an even match we're gonna get
our knight a3 again and we have
five minutes remaining this is both
players
with great chances this is insane i
i think by the end of this match uh eric
is going to turn that crew neck into a
v-neck
i mean he is just chomping away there
robert bishop f5 we're back to this
opening
i actually liked how this was for levy
last time but i don't agree that he
should have traded so many pieces
and eric plays rook b1 and he can play
b4a for b5 that's the idea i was calling
for
the bishop on f4 is so strong taking
away the b8 square and that's important
because the b
file opens up the rook on b1 has control
the rook on a8 or f8 cannot get to b8 so
knight to d7 he's bringing his piece
away from the king side queen d2 bishop
h6 is an idea
if you move your kick piece away i can
go attack you but rook g8 of course is
going to be e8
yeah and this is going to be the classic
setup don't underestimate that knight on
d3
kind of a hero guards the b2 pawn so the
rook and queen both do not have to worry
about it and it's watching both the c5
and the e5 squares knight g3 you can
already see where that knight might be
heading maybe the h5
to support queen over to h6 but usually
in these positions robert
black actually uses the open file to
attack white more than the other way
around
yeah and i think that with this bishop
trade here if you take and play rook g6
that looks good for black i might
put my bishop back because your pieces
are fighting for the g file
your bishop on g7 wants to get out of
there so bishop f4 for example says yeah
that's
staying close because knight e5 but now
i see yeah there's a pin on the f2 pawn
so there could be a rook takes g3 that
you have to look out for
yeah and we both tuned into that
immediately the queen on b6
looking at the king on g1 you might say
well there's so many things in the way
but keep in mind that rook on g8 looking
at taking that mga 3 for free but i
don't think it's quite working it's just
an idea to keep in mind for calculations
and he goes knight d7 so he retreats and
now bishop g7 knight h5
white can play for that mission we were
talking about but the e5 pawn is that a
strength
helping white secure the f6 square or is
it a weakness because it's already under
attack
it's so tough to tell rook g6 uh looks
reasonable knight to f4 of course can be
played and that rook might just slide
back to g7
big question is can white play queen to
d4 offering a queen trade and then try
to take over the c file
and that's something that's easy to miss
because you're so focused on the king
side but if the c file opens up and
white can get both rooks over there that
could be problematic for black and i
like king and shoe just
maybe saying it looks nice like going
all the way like switching sides so
quickly queen d
queen h4 in two moves the queen went
from b6 to h4 and suddenly there's a
king side attack and there's queen d4
watch out for knight h5 knight f6 but
the g2 pawn was hanging so he goes g3
good move
10 seconds per side 94 hits the f2 pawn
maybe a sack on g3 if you're not careful
so he plays rook to e2
and there's no sacrifice on g3 it will
not work so he's not going to go for now
whatever knight three
do not allow that fork six seconds my
goodness okay he brings the queen back
very very very crucial to stop that
knight goes back to e4 h4 played quickly
but i think this is going in levy's
direction there are so many sacrifices
on each four to worry about queen d8
oh my god it's hanging there's going to
be my gosh and if you move your knight
there's a knight takes g3 and the queen
d4 is hanging
one second you barely got to move
because brook takes h f4 and
it's mate and four seconds for levy and
he takes it quick
the queens trade the queen oh the rook's
hanging that's huge that's you yeah if
i'm eric you gotta resign you gotta well
i guess you only have time for one more
regardless but
levy is about to take the lead in this
match and it's up to eric rosen to
i think he's gonna resign here or not
sure if he knows the situation but
he's gonna get one more game anyway so
it doesn't matter it all comes down to
that game if he doesn't win
and the game is over by timeout if he
does not win this game
it is all over robert and one of the
most insane comebacks that we've ever
seen
is about to be upon us and did you see
levy hold his heart
i i don't know if he could take much
more of this i don't know if i can take
much more of this
but we get this funky variation with the
queen on e2 blocking the bishop
but levi he's been having success with
his king darting over the queen
side but this is different it's not the
position we've seen before whoa
what is that g4 h5 in a game where i
only need to draw i'm not sure i'm going
for this
wow and h6 played very quickly by rosen
he doesn't want to calculate anything he
says look
this saves my bishop that's all i need
to know and look at the swiss cheese and
the dark squares on the king side over
here
and the king can go to queen side for
what you just castle right now but then
watch out for
d4 and e5 and c5 and i don't like this
position for white
yeah all of a sudden that bishop on h7
wide awake and looking at that c2 pawn
you're not going to take it right now
but it's about the pressure
black's going to play c5 knight c6 maybe
knight before knight d4
and all of a sudden the knight and
bishop work together on the c2 pawn and
a5 he says look if you were ever
thinking about casting that way
don't forget i've got an attack coming
oh gosh and now the b4 square is
blacks for the taking bishop takes c2
everybody was not possible because this
d3 movement to trap the bishop
uh so oh actually the b3 pawn was
hanging so after a4 that could have been
a blunder
and maybe he could have taken c2 i
wasn't looking but here no matter what
terrible this is really bad for white in
a
you don't need to win this game you just
need to draw c3 that b3 square the d3
pawn maybe there's a knight c5 hitting
both at once
and it seems like white's position on
the verge of collapse look at the time
he's gonna flag this game in the opening
bishop c3 takes takes there's like queen
b4
queen d4 so many winning winning moves
here oh my gosh queen c5 queen d4
everything looks good
he goes bishop e7 no he missed something
he missed something there for
sure richard one is available oh gosh
but roxy one that's also ugly he goes
bishop
no we need to use his knight takes yeah
i forgot about that piece i was going
for the fork d4 though just push d4
yeah or bishop c5 bishop's e5 g5 is also
great for sure
at 26 and 25 to 10 he plays c5 i don't
like that movie either knight f3
all of a sudden white's getting
developed you need a rook h2 he's not
developing anything
and eric's just trying to play c4
himself because that bishop on h7 might
be the hero at the end
how do you stop c4 c4 is is going to
hurt and you've
you need to move like once a piece he
loses the beast and eric's going to win
and tie the match
oh my gosh he's 25
we're still in this game we're still in
this game oh are we
yeah we are because anything can happen
when you have votes from we made it with
a point one
he made up one point five he's barely
getting off
take it black is completely winning but
we'll see how the nerves are here
because i'm nervous bro
six the queen on eight six five shot
oh my gosh he takes it with a rook
that's a good move he's still winning
two pieces for the rook
put a knight on e3 watch out for knight
e takes into a 93 check
yeah that's e62 oh my goodness it's
saying there's also queen g6
and you can just you can check this
knight g493 do
something thank you for check here comes
oh my gosh if there's not a check me in
a few moves
i don't know how my time is a time match
oh my goodness we have a tie
and somebody's alarm went off you know
what that means it's not time to wake up
it's time for this time break time yep
that was that was my tie break alarm
there robert
and let's read the tie breaks so it is a
tie right now
it is 10 and 10 now we get four
additional
bullet games it's a mini match if you
score two and a half points
you win if it's tied two to two
we go to armageddon where white gets
five minutes
black gets three minutes but with the
draw odds and what we see early in the
match
black was winning all the games hey i
want to pick black but i get
three minutes we've seen the time
trouble this match hey i'm not going two
minutes down from move one
so amman the player with the higher
blitz rating
choose the color that means levy will
choose the color
if we get to armageddon i don't know if
we'll get that far but what would you
choose
well robert let me start off by saying i
didn't even know we had tie break rules
we hardly ever get to use them but it is
so exciting
to be in a tie break format what color
would i choose honestly the black pieces
have been stellar
for both sides today they cannot be
underestimated and
i think it's less about what color you
would choose and more about
how comfortable and how confident these
players are going to be containing their
nerves
because this has been one of the most
exciting matches i think we've ever
hosted and they get no break they're
going right back into things and
that i mean who's that better for eric
won the last game
but levy seemed to be the better of the
two that far in the bullet he came back
from one point down tied the match
he was up by a point until that last
game there so
he was storming back eric says hey not
so fast let's go to tie break
who has the edge psychologically as we
go into tie breaks
well eric rosen does because he's stone
cold the entire time he's doing that
how how did he not break a sweat crack a
smile no
show of emotion um but in all
seriousness no this is a
literal toss-up robert uh i i cannot
possibly call this both players playing
so clutch under pressure
and we saw that thumbs up clearly the
team behind the scenes doing all the
work
informing the players exactly what's
going on of course they could read the
rules beforehand they
likely have but just reminding them
because tie breaks don't happen very
often it is
four game mini match two and a half
points wins and well we've seen anything
can happen in bullet eric wins that
final game
levy probably feeling a bit shaken
because he just need to draw he started
playing wildly
and the nerves are getting to both of
them even if eric has
not moved a muscle except to bite his
sweatshirt a little bit
yeah this is going to be a series of
very intense matches because
it could so easily go to armageddon it's
been that connect the entire time
i think that levy has done a bit better
in the bullet but
when it mattered when he needed a win
eric rosa just stepped up to the plate
and played the best game of the match
and here we go we're going to get this
knight a3 line i am sure
and bishop b3 c3 here comes knight a3 to
c2
we've liked these positions for the most
part for eric but this bishop f1
51 excuse me that's been going pretty
well for levy yeah and i don't see why
he wouldn't go back to it uh there's
also his e6 line that he's been playing
with knight e4 but
g6 bishop f5 and look did he check that
in the last like five seconds
i'm not sure if he did but he said no
bishop f5 for you you could play e5 and
get the iqp
and levy says not for me i'm playing e6
and maybe b5 but we've liked those
positions for white that's for sure
yeah maybe knight e4 with f5 yeah
exactly and this
is another setup it's not easy to play
the move f3 to kick that knight out when
the move h3 is on the board the dark
squares get too weak
and this feels like it's a move behind
for black's amount because we saw f5 was
already there in 97 the queen a5
position
so somehow black seems to be down
on g7 instead of d6 it takes an extra
move to fianchetto
and that's good because stairs is a d4
pawn but now how does black get out of
this a3
to kick the knight that's why it goes
knight back to f6 but we like that
knight in the center and now
maybe c5 b4 push those queen side pawns
that has some risk for the d4 pawn
though
yeah but it's so it's so easy and bullet
to do something like that you know what
your next bunch of moves are going to be
and it just helps you play quickly and
get up on the clock as you see that's
already the case
and a5 is a great move stopping b4
before it can happen knight g4 let's
turn off the knights if you take me i
take towards the center
my pawn and d4 is protect i'll bring my
bishop to e3 so i like this decision but
black and try for
b6 trying to break open that position
yeah
knight takes g4 or you can just leave it
and play d6
he says no e5 and i like that response i
don't know what the evaluation is but
he wants to get that bishop out from ca
i both like it and dislike it the bishop
wants c8s out but so is that bishop on
c1 if you took an e5 the bishop would go
to h6 that's why he took on c5 but he
could bishop e3 bishop d4
planting that bishop on d4 and powerful
look at levy say no not for you
here comes d4 but that pawn on d4 could
be weak queen d6 or queen v6 hitting the
b2 pawn
keep in mind queen d2 guarding the pawn
g4 just hangs as a result
and black's going to bring the rooks to
c8 d8 and i feel like i like this
position for levy
and f3 says i'm going to protect but do
not move that bishop from d3 you move
that bishop d3 check happens
and that could be a problem so he goes
queen c2 why is control of the open file
black has this passport on d4 i feel
like white should be a little bit better
and queen e6 is an idea you have to be
careful
i don't like queen v6 queen d6 annoying
so i like bishop f8 to prevent queen d6
so maybe queen b5 queen a7 we've seen
queen e7 win some games but that could
lose you the game as your queen's really
far away
he just takes that's the modest queen c4
and look at that he dragged the bishop
out so he could attack the pawn
queen seven a good response there's no
quincy one don't blind your queen there
yeah no if either queen penetrates the
position specifically black's queen
uh it might be all over but look at
those bishops that either defending two
seconds
once oh my gosh he barely got that move
off in time and we should be seven
almost shot the queen there's queen
eight to get away from it it's a queen
city oh boy that's a that's a draw
that's true if he wants it there might
be more
i don't know where more is but maybe
there is more kingdom does that secure
the draw at this point
he is thinking about bishop f1 but he
should not play that movie he did it oh
my goodness
oh my gosh and he does it wait check
he missed it without king f2 king of two
bring your kingdom bishop c5
hey wait is there d2 big a3 oh d2 d2 is
winning
wow and that decision by eric he shook
his head the first
real reaction we've seen from him he was
like i can't believe that just happened
i played bishop f1 was so unnecessary he
didn't need to do that you just be okay
with the draw and go to the next game
sometimes you play for a win you play
for a loss and that's what's happening
here
levy keeps his composure with seconds
maybe even just
barely half a second on his clock in
certain moments and he is winning
this game it takes a one game lead in
this mini match
yeah i mean we're still in this game but
this is going to be a win
for levy yeah he has an extra piece
and now he can take him play bishop g7
trade off the bishops and then promote
the pawn yeah i think bishop f8 bishop
g7 is the easiest i mean look at rosen
he's
going for stalemate he's going for
stealing close to it
oh look at that taking the bishop and
you can just go bishop c6 and then
take the queen and then promote no
stalemates for you
i mean he's so close every time though
and i feel like that takes the wind out
of eric's sales because he won that
final game to send this to the tie
breaks
and he's the one who chose to play on
and levy was like waiting for it
he says you're going to have three
seconds i am going to win this game and
now levy rosman up
one point three games remaining in this
mini match
yeah and we see already a different move
knight f3 instead
of the f3 we've been seeing and one
thing we've said
and we've seen from eric rosen is he is
clutch robert you cannot deny that when
he needed to win
he won the game he needs to win right
now to get back in this
he certainly does and look at this setup
if white plays d4 to challenge the
center black plays e4 takes up space and
especially with that bishop with d6 so i
like the c4 move
challenging the center in a different
way and that pawn d5 is not protected
right now and it could be some problems
in the light squares
yeah and knight takes d5 we've seen
positions like this before in this match
with the f6 but
those light squares always a force to be
reckoned with this bishop on g4 there
might be a d4 move
a5 looks super strong and a6
soften up all the light squares over
there and watch out your knight on c6
not well defended so bishop back to e6
okay a6
b6 the problem with a6 is that pawn
later in the game can become a target
but right now it's such a problem for
black the rook can't move from a the a7
pawn needs defense
e4 once again you do not want to open
the position if you're playing uh
with the black pieces here something
like f5 we've seen a structure exactly
like this
earlier on maybe oh i was going to say
knight f6 made more sense than knight c8
yeah knight c8 that's not a fun move to
play
and i think the bishop can go to b4 as
well maybe not now because the rook's in
c1 but
this is not the way you want to go for
eric and he puts his pieces look at that
default
so clogged and if you can get f4 that
would be good but now cc77
yes at least in exchange there yeah
wha what do you do about this i think
you buy c takes d he thinks for the
knight but i was taking the c pawn up in
97 just i would lose my rook but
not the pawn knight f6 maybe had to be
played there or
something like that oh this is rough
this is rough
knight takes a8 bishop takes d6 and levy
once again
is just cementing this this uh position
although he doesn't win the more
material he does simplify that's a great
move bishop c4
trade off some stuff there will not be
an attack for black in fact white is
controlling the c
file so here comes the queen down to c8
c7 and the a7 pawn that's probably going
to be
lost soon yeah maybe knight f8 simply
forced
here rook c6 berks c7 looks great and
you mentioned there's going to be no
attack for black he can try desperately
with f4
but h5 none of these moves are actually
threatening anything
no and here comes queen c4 if you wanted
to try 87 yeah
that's nice and rook c1 rook c7 that
pawn is going to be taken and i
i think this is another win for levy
look he had 38 seconds robert
yeah something just you know snapped in
eric and he was playing really well he
won that final game but this one was
never his once
levi struck with c4 and then the knights
got awkward in a4a5
really nice play by levy knight c7 rook
takes a7
king c6 he's trying to trap that rook
but keep in mind there's always rook b7
check
yeah and he takes g7 the a pawn goes and
while you're up
pawns on both sides of the board
initially exchange and now all levy
needs is a draw
one draw wins in the match and eric
going back to his favorite weapon here
with knight
a3 yep this is a draw wins the match
there's four
games it's a four game mini match and
it's already two
nothing for levy rosman you can see the
two point advantage reflected in the
score he's back to this bishop f5 system
and
eric rosen's saying look that whole
knight e3 thing forget that let's go
back to the basics and what has worked
in the past
yeah he goes 93 now so he takes away the
f5 square
and the knight on f6 needs to keep an
eye on the d5 pawn so you have to watch
out for that because 28 protecting
getting his queen back and i still like
these positions for white it's just
my preference levy has done nothing
wrong it's solid it just feels
much more easy to play from the white
side yeah and i think he somehow got the
best version
almost all match like he's got the
bishop out in front of the knight on e3
and knight e4 can be instantly kicked
away by by simply f3
and knight a5 trying to get to the c4
square i was thinking that white would
play knight c1 knight b3 knight c5 but
now the 985 covers the b3 series bishop
g5 watch out for knight g4
that's going to be a very frustrating
pin and if you play h6 the bishop just
goes back to h4 so queen of c7 that's
good getting out of the pin
and we get a little repetition a little
tickle levi is going to take the
repetition and i think we know why he
wins the match with a draw keep that in
mind
uh going forward in this and that's a
sneaky move because if you ever play h6
you could have a problem with that
square so 94 hitting the bishop
he takes that's a big choice i was just
going forward he wants the dark squares
but i think he could have had them
without trading
yeah but he came with bishop f4 and then
knight to e5 so that way
he doesn't drop a pawn to get the knight
to e5 right now i don't think 96 check
is good
no knight h6 king h8 and you your knight
is actually just trapped on h6 you might
wish that it was back there bishop f4
great move and if you can bring that
knight to e5 you're saying that bishop
on c8
even though it can get the b7 maybe to
d5 perhaps there's nowhere for it to
attack
and you would like to trade off some of
these miners yep knight to e5 we haven't
even seen development completed by levi
is he gonna go knights before he does
take that off take and bishop h6 and
play knight against light squad bishop
that's what i would be doing
i know it's not a classical game but it
feels like black doesn't have any active
play
and white's just jumping in here yeah
but keep in mind that bishop if it gets
to d5
clogs the position all of a sudden it
could be black going f4
and where is white's play that's true i
was thinking that i would get my knight
to f4 but you're right if you can kick
my pieces out of there and then press
four that could be a problem so b3 now
play b3 open up that other flank b3 but
b3
c takes b3 you can't stick with the rook
there's bishop a4 so you have to be
careful a little bit bishop c6 to d5 now
and he's not getting b3 i think
bishop d5 if he doesn't play b3 there's
no play left
yeah maybe h4 to try to crack the king
side as well but here's g5
oh oh here comes f4
wow and the bishop does cement itself
and if you take on c4 the bishop lands
there can you even go to defense
look at the clock as well there's eight
seconds he's in a tough position
clock ticking down but we've seen him be
clutch before this is still anyone's
game
yeah and watch out for the king side
attack if you go f4 you drop e4 the g5
pawns in attack it goes queen g6
that's a good move but you have trouble
playing f4 for black so he plays h4 but
now f4 the pawn still could be hanging
i like to move rook before yes whoa it
takes a night that's shocking
very shocking well there's gonna be g4
to follow but uh eric rosen has got to
be happy with his chances here
yes because now all things are opening
up and rookie three very good
f4 oh no or maybe not the three move f3
and go for checkmate oh my gosh this
might be so quickly
rookie three play but g takes h3 and the
queen comes down to g2
and that looks like game h2 okay but
you can't stop h2 there goes the pawn
get a queen
yeah a draw oh he's fist pumping
he's fist bumping he's still got the
game to complete but the queening
and he's got it he's up a rook and there
has to be a checkmate in the next few
moves so
levy rosman against all odds he was down
three points at some moment
here he goes checkmate next move and
that is the match and look at
levy he is elated there is a fist bump
he's gone it's probably jumping around
his room i feel sorry for
whatever objects he has around him
they're probably breaking right now
holy smokes the emotions finally pour
out because they've been bottled in the
entire match
rosen and rosman just gave us probably
one of the best treats
ever for in terms of entertainment
robert
you know bringing you this prime time
show i'm not a gm maybe any speed chess
championship
match i feel like this has been the most
exciting it really was and it kind of
got to be a little bit of a frozen rosin
in these time scrambles he was using a
lot of time levy was just locking things
up and he couldn't find the right moves
even when he had his chances of real
credit to both of these players
we got to take our final break because
we need to return with them we can hear
their thoughts
and we're gonna have to know what was
going on with the black pieces winning
the first nine games of the match so
stay tuned everybody
we'll be back with levy and eric very
shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back i know the chat is going
wild right now
uh from that completely insane match in
terms of entertainment
robert and i are on the edge of our
seats we have the players levy and eric
joining us here
and i i just go right to you levy the
the emotions we saw them come pouring
out of you
on camera right at the end there some
fist bumps we were worried about you
know the projectiles and some of the
objects in your room but
can you just describe how you're feeling
after an insane match victory
uh i mean yeah what what to say um first
of all
uh eric that was a lot of fun uh we
should do that again
just maybe not so soon uh in a few days
right
i i mean i i at some point i gave up
preparing for eric
you just can't do it uh and so as the
match was kind of spiraling out of
control i actually
when i went three down i left and i and
i went to talk to my girlfriend and i
was like
mentally i was preparing what i was
gonna say when i when it was over and i
lost
because i was just okay i mean and then
i don't know
it just moved pieces to squares and
uh yeah i mean at the end it's just
raw emotion what else to say no
absolutely it was a really heated match
it was going back and forth
and eric let me ask you something the
match started
with nine wins for the players with the
black pieces so
what was going on did that kind of feel
weird to you or was that just
par for the course of what was going to
be a wild match yeah it was a little bit
strange um
i was i wasn't really keeping track but
i knew
that it seemed like black for some
reason had the upper hand
and that may have been because that we
both prepared very well for black and
not so well for white
oh not not at all i mean like most of
the games were coming down to
like much later moments and these crazy
time scrambles so
it may have been psychological may have
been coincidental but um
uh yeah levy levy played well especially
to come back
from i think he was at a three-game
deficit
yeah so twice right
it was rough but uh i'm really i was
really hoping you wouldn't keep playing
e4
um but then you kept playing e4
yeah i wanted to keep punishing your
kero khan but
maybe in hindsight maybe i should have
switched to london
i was like waiting at some point at some
point i pre-moved c6 and i got very
scared because i was like
um yeah i don't know about eric but like
i i
you look at some lines and then you're
like okay i'll you'll just figure it out
um i was pretty unhappy with with some
of the five plus one i still can't
figure out how to play the time control
correctly of course like we barely play
it so
uh i felt those positions were a lot of
fun but
for the first i mean for the almost the
entire five plus one basically the
entire three plus one it just felt like
eric was
more clutch held his nerves better um
outplayed me like i mean there was
moments i was staring at the board and
he played a move and i'd be like oh yeah
like not even that it's good that it's
legal that he'd play a move and then he
was just
once it was three down i just kind of
was like okay whatever we'll see what
happens and then i had nothing in the
next game and
yeah i don't know just momentum swings i
just i wore a fitbit to track my heart
rate i was telling eric
and uh i averaged 130 beats per minute
for like the last hour so probably
pretty unhealthy for me to keep playing
these matches
yeah i was saying the same thing it
would be a good thing that robert and i
did not have heart monitors on the
screen because ours were definitely up
there as well
um erica go to you again because it
looked like you made a decision i was
wondering if it was conscious
or not at the end of the three minute
portion it looked like you resigned to
take another game
um and you know that game obviously
ended up going too
levy kind of shrunk that lead you know
is that an intentional decision and is
it something you sort of look back on in
this match
yeah um it was a conscious decision i
was aware
that there was like i think 15 seconds
left of the 3-1
portion and i was debating whether to
resign just yet another game um
and i mean i i was liking my prep
preparation with white so i think
if i was in the same situation again i
probably would have made the same
decision but
of course the game uh that was probably
one of my
worst losses is white because i just
blundered this uh
this bishop b4 move levy played really
tricky that final game so
he got that uh that momentum shift high
praise honestly i
like i said i was just the last few
games was just making moves and then you
played queen c3 and i was like
oh uh and you know playing eric is like
it's kind of a nightmare because when
you play most title players you get
upper rook
like okay next game but with eric it's a
constant lingering fear that he will
completely embarrass you and he almost
did he i almost almost he almost
got a stalemate trap like in the first
section or something
and i'm constantly sitting here with
this fear like i'll end up on a
highlight somewhere you know
and uh it's no it's the stress is never
over until he
the game literally pops up that i it's
over and i won
the stress is insane well levi let me
ask you something because you mentioned
momentum shifts and
stress when eric won that final bullet
game to tie the match and send
the tie breaks that's a momentum shift
eric's way how did you calm yourself
because you didn't even get time to rest
before going into more bullet
what were you saying to yourself what
were you thinking you know what was that
experience
like to be honest i would love to give
you some big inspirational speech but um
it ended um i knew i mean that whole
that game i must have hit 150
throughout the game i just like kept
trying to calm down and kept playing
garbage moves
it was really a fun process and i was
like you know we'll just play
and at that point i really expected d4
because i'm like okay it's brand new
four games and he plays e4 and then we
get another
like what i don't even remember what
what iteration of the move order it was
and like i said i was just gonna put
pieces on squares and try to play the
best move and try not to get low on time
and uh i got my chance and then in the
next game i don't even remember what
opening i played in the second game of
the bullet
but um oh i played this like b3 bishop
b2 e3 and i made that decision i made
consciously i was like the next time he
does that i'm going to play that but
other than that just stay focused and uh
hope for the best that's basically it
right
i mean this this entire match basically
felt like uh it came down to a match of
nerves especially with all the time
scrambles
and you yourself eric pretty much on
camera i think
everyone would echo these thoughts that
you look like
nothing phases you you know you'll
you'll hang the biggest blunder of the
match
and you'll look the same as when you
have that clutch victory
to send the entire match into armageddon
can you give some insight are you
actually nervous under there at all
or are you just unphased in these
scrambles well i'm i'm actually curious
uh maybe next time i do one of these
matches i should wear a heart rate
monitor
because i get nervous but um i mean one
of the ways to calm
nerves is just to not show anything and
just kind of
try and find that sort of zen mode
so um of course like i'll feel the
adrenaline but um i don't think there's
too much reason for me to get emotional
or like if i have a tough loss or
blunder something i'm not gonna like
throw anything or break anything so it's
one of those things that
uh i've lost lost enough games over my
uh
my career to kind of cope and just move
on with uh
just take it one move at a time yeah
that makes sense and you mean levy in
one of those games
it's hard to call it any moment a moment
of the match but there was that rook
takes f7 so the queen takes up seven and
you have queen b1
and saw that checkmate on the back rank
like moments like that like how do you
play
in next game because whether you win or
lose that
there's so much emotional adrenaline
rushing through you like how do you just
gear yourself up to keep going
um well you you have to actually was
that the
wasn't there was there a break after no
no we there was another game there was
another game one more after that yeah
yeah
um i mean i think it's different what
time format you do it and i think in
five plus one
it it's like it takes forever for the
game to kind of get going
uh that was actually a game i was
talking about i was winning and then
eric
like defended really well i mean and i
got low on time and
in my head i'm thinking highlight
highlight reel highlight reel i'm losing
losing losing and then as i play rook f7
i'm like if he takes with the rook i
have queen b1 with like 1.5 seconds on
the clock you know and he takes
i barely got the move there first of all
like you know mouse moving like this
and then it was just mate um but i did
the same thing against canty i uh
i had a good win and then the next game
i completely self-destructed um
yeah i mean when i was basically losing
games during the breaks i would like
walk outside i would do the daniel
cormier i would walk
like one way to down my apartment and
then one way back and just like be like
let's go like come on like focus and
then i would like sit back and lose more
games it was a really
cathartic experience i must say um now i
won't sleep till three in the morning i
don't know about eric but
ah yes and
eric i do have another question for you
and one of those games
in the bullet i think it was the first
tiebreak game if i'm not mistaken
you'd made this decision to bring your
bishop back to f1 instead of repeating
moves
with king g1 to h2 and i hate to bring
up bad memories
but what was your thought process like
there because levi did not have much
time
but it felt like you could go for the
repetition and go to the next game so
how did you make that decision
to sort of play for a win ah i i was
just about to suppress the memory and
then you you brought it up
eric you know we're friends i'm sorry
i'm so sorry i forgive you
um yeah it was kind of a practical
decision i um
i mean levy had two seconds left and i
saw
that he shouldn't be queening
but then he had a promotion tactic to
win
a piece and then i was just lost so of
course that was uh
that was unfortunate because i could
have just taken a draw and then
moved on but um it was it was kind of a
calculated risk in the moment
and that didn't pay off
yeah i think that's the that's the best
summary an honest answer i mean
those are just game time decisions comes
down to just seconds
uh i think it's fair to say this was
literally one of the most exciting
scc matches and i am not a gm and maybe
in just sec overall
that most people can remember that i can
certainly remember commentating
it went all the way to a tie break it
nearly went to armageddon
so i think that just speaks how to how
closely matched
the entire thing was um go over to you
levy
and you know congrats because you you
did come out
uh on top with the roller coaster of
emotions and you're probably not
thinking about it but
you are moving on in the competition and
greg jihadi is waiting for you
on the other side of the bracket um any
thoughts towards that match or
you know just kind of trying to get the
heart rate down
i think i think it's down no it's still
above 1.05 so
uh my resting heart rate is like 59 so
it's going to be a while
um uh no i mean greg is really strong
uh he actually it's funny he messaged me
before the tournament began and he was
like you want to talk some trash like on
social media he's very like
contrary to what he like puts out on
twitter i'm like man i'm not even sure
i'll even make to make it to play this
man it wasn't a matter of him he would
he would make
he's fine um i was like we'll see you
know because the first time we did this
i was knocked out in the quarterfinal
i'm like we'll see when we get there so
i don't know man um this time i tried to
drink some wine in the beginning of the
match to like cool off that didn't work
i almost fell asleep
who knows next time i don't
yeah well it's late for both of you uh
we appreciate you
taking the time and everyone was
delighted and treated to a great match i
mean there's so many people still here
it was the numbers were through the roof
and everybody was
rooting for both so we really appreciate
you coming on playing a great match and
obviously for all the work you do
for chess in general it's an absolute
joy to
see you both thrive and the numbers
speak for themselves
so it's a lot of fun guys well i i hope
the commentary was fun
um shout out to you know everybody in
the chat i saw the energy was electric
it's a good it's a it's a
it's a healthy rivalry you know i should
say that eric is
uh one of the only probably the person
i've known the longest in
all of this online over-the-board stuff
um he's one of the only people who
at the beginning of last year i even saw
in person because he stayed at my place
or was that january
that was yeah that was january last year
yeah i mean it's like crazy how much has
changed so
ah that was good it was good to play
this match if i was gonna lose to
anybody
i was gonna be happy to lose to eric
same with you levy
but um we're gonna you know go back to
the drawing board
keep uh keep making content streaming
and uh
shout out to you guys for hosting and
shout out to the chat for being
electric well we appreciate it good word
that's a good word for the chat electric
was exactly the energy
and uh another congrats to you levy but
especially
eric for making this uh literally one of
the most uh memorable
matches for for everyone here so
congrats to both and thanks again for
taking the time to join us all right
thanks guys
have a good night you too and there you
see it
the bracket is set the final four it is
greg shahadi levy rosman roberto molina
lars oscar hogg amon we just had a
wonderful match
and if we look forward we see levy
taking on greg you asked him he said
well there was potential for trash talk
he didn't give a definitive answer on
what his thoughts were what are your
thoughts on both
that match and the roberto versus lars
match
uh it's it's actually pretty incredible
to uh remind ourselves robert that that
wasn't the final
you know what i mean that felt like a
finals match so
that just speaks volumes about how
closely matched those two players are
levy moving on he's taking on greg
greg's the number one seed
we all know that he uh comes into this
you know he must be the the
favorite on paper but we've seen so many
ups and downs
from levy it could be you know his
terrible time management might cost him
the entire
five-minute segment or his resilience
in the bullet might win him the whole
match so i think it's a very interesting
matchup but
i will say that levy probably knows
himself he needs to
find a way he mentioned it in our
interview here needs to find a way to
play the five-minute segment properly
because
he just doesn't have any practice in
that exact format
format five minutes plus one second
increment and greg jihadi has
so much experience he's obviously older
than levy he's been playing blitz as a
favorite of his for a long long time you
can go on youtube and find really old
clips of him doing that
he is higher rated he's the number one
seed so far it's been rock chuck jayhawk
one through four making it to the
semi-finals and
levy has his work cut out for him but
what is showing we don't even want to
think ahead at this point we'll just
focus on the match that was
because we have two fantastic streamers
who can also play some mean chess
that was awesome it was wholesome to
hear their thoughts their friends
when they're not competing against one
another and eric despite the loss he
proved that
he was every bit the match for levy
rosman
and we could not have asked for a better
show no there's no other way to put it
um the the chat i think i don't know
what the the max viewers was but it was
upwards of 22 to 25 000
uh watching so so many fans of both
of these players and just chess fans who
maybe haven't
uh seen these guys hey these guys are
active streaming on twitch all the time
you know so if you you liked uh what you
saw today
you can get a another taste of that on
on their channels respectively so
just a an incredible incredible day i
had a feeling this was going to be
one of the most hyped matchups uh prime
time slot
uh we got our producers staying up until
7 00 a.m plus
uh uh their robert just to make this
show happen
so i'm glad i'm glad we did because it's
been a pleasure
i don't know what my heart rate is i
don't know how i'm going to sleep
tonight but that was
a great match and we want to thank
everybody who's been tuning in
throughout this whole way
between two very popular chess
personalities gotham chess i am rosen
there could be only one winner it was
levy but on behalf of myself and amman
gonna say goodbye say goodnight and
we'll see you soon for more chess
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you